Mental focus follows visual focus.
We have an aperture or a window on our focus.
When you are excited about something
or you really want to attend to something,
it literally brings about a narrowing of the aperture
of your visual window,
so that you attend to this particular location in space.
(upbeat music)
And yet,
if you think about the way our world is arranged now,
with your phone calling you over to this location
and whatever's happening in your immediate environment
and things that are happening within your body,
you realize that,
"Oh, it makes perfect sense why focus is hard."
(upbeat music)
I think we all owe it to ourselves to ask,
"Well, what kind of environment am I creating myself,
and what simple things can I do to try
and enhance my ability to focus?"
Because I'm personally of the belief that if possible,
start with behavioral tools.
Hey, everybody, welcome to the podcast.
Today's guest, very exciting,
back for round two
is Stanford neuroscientist, Dr. Andrew Huberman.
Andrew's first appearance
is by far the most watched and listened to episode
in the history of this podcast with,
as of today's date while I'm recording this,
over 10 million views here on YouTube alone.
Dr. Huberman is a neuroscientist
and tenured professor of neurobiology and ophthalmology
at Stanford University School of Medicine,
where he runs the Huberman Lab,
which studies neuro-regeneration, neuroplasticity,
and numerous brain states.
He's also the host
of the wildly popular Huberman Lab podcast,
which in its first year
has become one of the top most listened to podcast
in the world.
In this conversation, we discuss mind body neuroscience,
the neuroscience of ADHD,
focus, hypnosis and processing trauma.
We talk about how to leverage light, temperature, breath,
and sleep to better control your biology
as well as tools for achieving optimal performance states.
We also talk about learning states
and the power of something called gap effects,
which is absolutely fascinating.
And many other topics.
Andrew is a passionate man.
He has this incredible facility
for communicating complex scientific topics
in a uniquely compelling and understandable way.
And this conversation for those of you keen
on better understanding how to control our minds,
our neurochemistry, all told our biology
is just straight up appointment viewing.
Final thing before we get started,
Andrew is gonna be hosting two live events this May;
one in Seattle, on May 17,
and one in Portland on May 18.
Ticket presales open on Tuesday, March 8,
which Andrew is gonna share on his social media
at HubermanLab, as well as on his website,
hubermanlab.com with a password,
and then general ticket sales are gonna open
on Friday, March 11.
These are gonna sell out fast.
So grab 'em quick and more information on all of this
can be found in the description below.
So here we go.
Round two with Dr. Andrew Huberman.
Good to see you, man.
Great to be back.
Great to have you back.
It's been quite a journey that you've been on.
I can't wait to get into it
and get into some really interesting terrain
that you've been looking at and studying.
But before we do that, let's just recap for a moment,
the first time you came on the podcast,
which I guess was,
that was about a year and a half ago, right?
I think it was July 2020.
July, 2020. Right.
So that podcast ended up becoming the most popular podcast
in the history of this show as of today,
I think we're at 9.9 million views on YouTube,
which is insane.
So thank you for that.
Thank you.
And sharing your wisdom,
but what's really cool is that at that moment in time
you hadn't even launched Huberman Lab,
the Huberman Lab podcast,
you end up starting the show in January of 2021.
And within ostensibly a year,
it's become one of the biggest podcasts in the world.
Each episode,
this sort of self-contained masterclass
on some facet of neuroscience
or related scientific terrain
and have kind of become like a social media,
internet superstar.
It's crazy, right?
Like how does this totally unintended feel?
How does it feel?
Well, I'm not big on mission statements,
but if I had to pick one and the thing that's nearest
and dearest to my heart is to try
and share the beauty and utility of biology.
I mean, that's what got me into science in the first place.
And I love learning and I love sharing what I learn,
and ever since I was a little kid,
I've felt this compulsion to share what I learn.
So in the sense that it gives me an avenue to do that
and that people are receptive
and hopefully learning from it,
and enjoying it, and it feels great.
It was not planned at all.
2020 'cause of the events in the world
I started going on podcasts.
I was fortunate to you and Lex Friedman, and Joe Rogan,
and others to gimme that opportunity,
and then the plan was to write a book at some point
about the work in my laboratory and related themes.
But one way or another, I ended up in the podcast realm.
Lex Friedman suggested I start a podcast and he said,
"I think you should start a podcast,
but whatever you do,
don't make it just you talking at the camera."
(both laughing)
So I followed the first part of the advice.
We do have guests on,
and those are actually my favorite episodes,
when I can host guests.
It gives me an opportunity to showcase amazing colleagues
that for the most part,
probably wouldn't get the opportunity
to share at that scale.
So that's wonderful.
And also they get the opportunity to get feedback
from the world and the encouragement,
'cause it can be a bit of a lonely road doing science.
So overall it feels wonderful.
I feel very gratified that people enjoy it
and I'm having fun.
Well, it's well earned and deserved
and it's actually quite heartwarming
to see so many people just gravitate towards
and embrace hard science in this way.
The idea that millions of people across the world
would hit pause on their life
and basically listen
to what is for the most part like a lecture, right?
In the way that you would lecture your students
at Stanford on pretty challenging topics
and do it in a way
where I think your gift really is as a communicator
to take these very complicated subjects
and figure out how to communicate the essence of them
in a way that is understandable to of the average person
without kind of pandering or condescending to them.
Yeah.
Well, my belief is that if you give people
a minimum of required nomenclature
that they can digest pretty much anything.
And the podcast weaves back and forth
between hardcore scientific mechanism,
and then we'll zoom out
and talk about daily relevance or lifetime relevance.
We definitely talk about protocols and things of that sort.
So sometimes I use an interest in some wellness
or health related tool as a way to teach mechanism,
and sometimes I do the opposite.
And so I'm trying to weave back and forth
in a way that makes it accessible regardless of background.
And I have to say one of the most gratifying things
has been when I hear from people in the clinical fields,
psychologists, or even yoga teachers,
or athletes, or coaches and school teachers,
and maybe even tools they're already using,
suddenly they feel like they can equip those
with some mechanism
that can recruit some additional students or attention.
So there are a lot of different ways to frame science
and mechanism,
but my belief is,
I think it was Max Still Brooks that said,
"Assume zero knowledge and infinite intelligence
or something like that,
are probably misquoted and misattributed,"
so someone can correct me,
but I do believe that if you give people the basics
that they can digest pretty much anything.
Yeah.
The core of the show is still you talking to the mic
or the camera.
How long does it take you to prepare
for these episodes, because they're so flashed out,
like clearly there's a ton of work and research
and preparation that goes into this.
Yeah, it depends on the topic.
So if it's something a little bit more neurosciencey
then less time,
but we've covered topics as far out as trauma,
and fear, and things of that sort,
which my lab works on related themes,
but I'm not a clinician.
So typically the process is,
we know what episode we're gonna plan for.
And then what I will typically do
is reach out to a few colleagues at Stanford and elsewhere,
I believe in the power of the telephone.
So I cold call people,
I track them down, I get them on the phone,
try and figure out who the key players in the area are
and then read papers related to their work
and other really important labs and clinics in that realm.
And then I dive into textbooks.
So my house is filling up with textbooks
and I'm really big on textbooks,
because it's hard to track
PubMed and the evolution of a field,
but in textbooks you get the kind of center of mass
of something.
And then of course I spend time on PubMed
and then I usually try and circle back to those colleagues,
make sure that everything I'm gonna bring about
is corrected down as well as it can.
And then where there's a place to speculate,
I'll comfortably speculate
and I'll highlight that it's speculation.
So the short answer is it takes it anywhere
from six to 24 working hours to prepare.
And then I take walks and I rehearse it in my head.
And then I sit down and I make my poor podcast producer
listen to the whole thing,
and sometimes a recording can take two hours
for an one and a half hour episode.
Sometimes it can take six and a half hours,
that all scales with how well rested I am the night before.
There's a very clear correlation with how well rested I am
and how well I can structure things with...
For sure.
But it's a labor of love. I really truly enjoy it.
Well, it's good.
It's a gift to humanity.
So I'm really glad that you're doing it.
And there's a lot of topics that I wanna cover today.
There's a million different threads that we could pull.
I sort of honed down on a couple
that I hope you can indulge me on.
The first thing that I'd like to get into is around focus,
improving focus, and perhaps even ADHD.
And the reason I wanna begin with this
is because it's sort of on my mind,
I recently had Johann Hari on the podcast,
who wrote this book "Stolen Focus,"
which is all about our declining ability
to sustain attention,
what the causes of that are from technology
and our mobile devices to stress, sleep, exercise,
connection with nature, connection to other people,
and the like.
But let's kind of approach this
from a neuroscience perspective.
Like how are you thinking about this
from a mechanistic point of view?
Yeah.
So a lot of people are struggling with focus
and I'll just point out
that there is a fair amount
of clinically diagnosed ADHD out there.
I think the current numbers are somewhere between 10 and 11%
of young folks are now diagnosed with ADHD.
And I think that's probably accurate.
I don't know whether or not
the numbers are going up with social media.
There's a lot of speculation about whether or not things
like ADHD and eating disorders
are increasing with socia media,
or whether or not they've been constant
in our ability to detect them is just getting better.
So that's an ongoing debate,
but the numbers are about 10 to 11%.
First of all, a couple,
I mean sort of pseudo myths to eliminate.
The first thing is that we are very good
at splitting our attention.
Humans can multitask.
All old world primates have what's called covert attention.
I can look at you and have a conversation with you
and I can attend to the glass,
that's just to the right of my right hand.
So I can split my attention into two cones.
I can also bring one of those cones of attention internally,
so I can pay attention to maybe
how fast my heart is beating right now
while I'm talking to you.
So it's a complete myth that we can't multitask.
We absolutely can multitask.
It's much harder to split our attention
into three cones of attention or four cones of attention,
but one thing that's very clear,
it's very well grounded in neuroscience
and this concept of covert detention
is that it has utility, right?
Covert detention has been thought to be useful
in the context of monitoring social circumstances.
So the typical neuroscience lecture form of this
is that monkeys in a big troop
would need to pay attention to who the dominant
and subordinate males and females are,
and govern their behavior accordingly.
In other words, pay attention to what's going around you,
going on around you,
not just to what you want to do and how the person or monkey
in front of you is behaving.
And humans do this too.
The common example that's used in neuroscience lectures
is a couple on a date out to dinner
and someone's attending to somebody else in the corner
that might have been a better date
or something or paying attention to that conversation.
Yeah, it's totally possible.
So we can split our attention.
But there's gotta be a distinction
between what your primary focus is lasered in on
versus whatever that kind of background multitask is, right?
Like you couldn't like write two essays
with each hand at the same time.
That's right.
And so that highlights a really important point,
which is that you can wait these cones of attention
and you can bring them together.
So the best way to think about 'em is two spotlights,
and you can bring both spotlights
to one common area of focus and get a deeper,
depth of focus if you will,
deeper depth sort of redundant there,
but you can get a more heightened state of attention
or focus by bringing those together.
Likewise, if I close my eyes and focus in entirely
on my internal state,
something we called interoception
to distinguish it from exteroception,
which is the view of the outside world.
You can pay attention to your heart beat,
to your breathing,
this is common to many meditative practices.
So we can split this thing that we call focus or attention
and we can wait this thing that we call focus and attention.
Now in ADHD, one of the less appreciated aspects
of the clinical phenotype,
meaning that the sorts of symptoms that show up,
it's commonly thought that people with ADHD cannot focus,
but that's simply not true.
If they are engaged in something
they really care about or like,
they can focus very intensely.
And that is because much of focus
relates to the dopamine system,
this neuromodulator/neurotransmitter that...
I know you had Anna Lamche, Mike gone here,
the neuromodulator dopamine plays a very active role
in motivation, craving and pursuit.
It's commonly thought that it's only associated with reward
and feel good type of behaviors or phenomenon,
but it's actually associated with pursuit of things
that at least we think are gonna make us feel good
in the short term.
So to kind of a generic currency for pursuit and motivation.
When we focus and when we are excited about something,
there is a lot of activity
in these so-called dopaminegic circuits.
And so it's not a surprise
in that many of the prescription medications for ADHD
are medications that amplify the amount of dopamine
that's available on the brain
through one mechanism or another.
So these would be your Ritalins, your Adderalls.
And then nowadays there's also a lot of prescribing
of things like Modafinil,
which is yet another category of drugs
used to treat ADHD slightly different,
and then in the kind of supplementation world,
people delve into things like L-Tyrosine,
which is the precursor to dopamine.
So there are a variety of ways
to access the dopamine system,
but the way that the dopamine system
was designed to enhance focus
is that when you are excited about something
or you really want to attend to something,
it literally brings about a narrowing of the aperture
of your visual window and your auditory window,
so that you attend to this particular location in space.
And then events within that location in space
for what you see, and what you hear,
movements of whatever you're attending to
become extremely important and extremely relevant.
And so it just highlights this larger theme
of how the brain and attends and unattend,
which is that we have an aperture or a window on our focus.
And dopamine seems to narrow that,
literally any drug, like any stimulant
like cocaine or amphetamine at the extreme,
but even caffeine will dilate the pupils causing that,
somewhat paradoxically
causes a narrowing of the visual window
and your ability to focus is enhanced.
And that brings about the perhaps the most important point,
which is that for most people
provided that they are sighted,
provided they can see, mental focus follows visual focus.
And for that reason,
there's a lot of exciting research being done in classrooms
and in clinical settings, training children,
into some extent adults,
but training children to anchor their visual focus
to maybe a crosshatch or a fixation point,
and just learn how to keep their visual attention
on a narrow aperture.
It's essentially training these...
It turns out before brain circuit,
so the front of the brain right behind the forehead
and some of these dopamine circuits deeper in the brain.
It's training those to engage
whenever the person deliberately wants to engage them.
So for most people, they hear this and they go,
"Oh, of course, mental focus follows visual focus,"
and yet,
if you think about the way our world is arranged now,
with your phone calling you over to this location
and your computer calling you to that location,
and whatever's happening in your immediate environment
calling to that location,
and things that are happening within your body,
it makes perfect sense
if you only have two cones of attention
and they're moving around like those lights that advertise
or used to be used to advertise some event in a city,
shining up in the sky, moving all over the place,
you realize that,
"Oh, it makes perfect sense why focus is hard."
We are now realizing that we need to try train up focus,
and whereas in the past,
when we weren't so inundated with devices and distraction,
that was probably easier to do.
We didn't need such rigid blinders,
but in fact, we do need blinders.
And many people actually benefit
from things like putting on a hoodie or wearing a hat,
actually limiting their visual window
and restricting their visual window
can be very helpful for people to learn
how to use visual focus to anchor cognitive focus.
Yeah. That makes a lot of sense.
I mean, I'm just thinking about,
let me throw this at you.
If I'm sitting down and I'm trying to write,
I can't focus on two things.
I have to focus on that one specific thing,
my vision is laser focused on that one thing
and I become very intolerant
to any kind of external stimuli.
I feel very fragile.
A notification can throw me off
and there's the switch cost effect of that,
versus, let's say I'm out on my bike on a training ride
and I'm listening to an audio book or a podcast,
I can do both of those things simultaneously,
and I would contend,
and I'm interested in your perspective on this.
I would contend that my memory retention
of what I'm listening to
is actually better when I'm out doing that
even though I'm focused on the exertion
of running on a trail, riding my bike,
something about the elevated heart rate
and the kind of controlled labored breath.
For some reason, that's a better combination
than if I was just driving around in my car,
trying to listen to it.
Yeah. It's exactly right.
I mean, what we're really getting to here
is this notion of brain states.
And I imagine this is something we might get into
repeated times throughout our conversation,
which is that just;
as just in sleep we have states of mind
that relate to dreaming or slow wave sleep,
or rapid eye movement sleep,
in our waking states,
our waking period, I should say,
we transition through various states.
And for some of us,
there are conditions in which we have so much activation
in our body, what we call autonomic arousal,
but so much energy, basically,
that just sitting down to write at the computer,
you would think, "Oh, well, this is very hard,
it should anchor all of my attention and energy
into this narrow cone of attention."
But the fact that you also have to sit still,
the fact that there's actually not just what's right
in front of you,
but there's also the internal dialogue
that you're carrying about,
"What's gonna happen with this passage?
Is this any good?
What someone gonna think?
Is a notification gonna go off in a moment?"
There are multiple scripts running.
And that's why we distinguish between this exteroception,
which is the perception of things in the outside world
and interoception,
which is the perception of things
within the confines of our skin.
And when we sit down to write,
we might think that it's just one thing in front of us,
but actually we're paying attention to internal events
and dialogues as well.
So we're splitting our attention in multiple ways.
When I can only speculate,
but I can imagine that when you're out for a ride,
a good amount of that excess autonomic arousal
is consumed by the pedaling and the breathing
that puts your brain into a kind of a rhythmic state.
And we know that breathing,
we know based on a lot of good data
that breathing sets a condition in the brain
for certain brain states to arise.
And this is very easily experienced
where if you slow down your breathing
and commit to doing maybe two or three breaths per minute,
you'll notice that your brain and your entire body
will shift into probably a more relaxed state
for most people.
And if you were to commit
to doing 15 or 30 breaths per minute,
your brain and body would shift into a more aroused state.
So over time,
I think almost everybody figures out
the things they need to do,
how much coffee, how much movement,
whether or not you work before or after your ride,
what sorts of information you consume
and what types of work one does
in order to try and optimize this process.
But a lot of what my laboratory is doing at Stanford
and what other laboratories are doing elsewhere
is to try and figure out, what are these brain states?
How do we define them?
What really is a state of focus
and how do we arrive at a state of focus if we're tired?
How do we arrive at a state of focus
if we are kind of over-agitated?
And so beneath all brain states,
including our ability to focus is this,
I like to visualize
as sort of a seesaw of autonomic arousal.
We can either be relaxed and alert,
which is kind of the optimal state
for most things besides sleep.
We can be very alert,
we can be panicked, or we can be very, very calm,
or we can be asleep.
So on one end you have calming type experiences or states,
and on the other end you have kind of amplified states.
If you are feeling really upset about something,
it's gonna be hard for you to focus
whether or not it's at the computer,
or whether or not it's out on your ride
while listening to this podcast
or whatever it happens to be.
So I think that in,
again, I can only speculate,
but I have to imagine that your ability to comprehend things
and remember things when you're out on these rides
is based on a number of things:
It's the familiarity with the process.
You're obviously very familiar with the bike.
It's also probably a subconscious familiarity
with a certain pace of riding
that allows your brain to access the state
in which you can digest information through audio.
I should say one kind of interesting set of studies
that's emerging now,
and I can't really report back on the data yet,
simply because we don't know,
is that some people who have trouble with attention,
especially while reading are finding it very beneficial
to listen to audio books while actually reading the book.
And I swear this is not an attempt
to get people to both purchase the audio book
and the written book.
I don't even have a book to promote at this point.
So that's not the purpose in this,
but we definitely are a species
that likes to combine our audio and visual world.
In fact, the maps of our visual world
and the maps of our audio world,
or our audition really,
and the maps of our motor world are in perfect register,
such that if we hear sound off to our right,
we turn to the right, not to the left.
If we hear something right in front of us,
meaning arrives at the two ears at the exact same time,
and what we call the Interaural time difference is zero,
well, then we look straight ahead.
And so it makes sense that when we can bring the audio world
and the visual world into alignment,
our focus is always going to be greatest
under those conditions.
Some people learn better through their visual field
than their auditory field, right?
Like I know if I'm reading a book
I'm in a better position to retain that information.
When I recall something that I've read in a book,
I see it on the page,
and when I hear it, it's much more elusive.
And I would assume that some people
are the opposite of that.
Yeah.
Some people are much more auditory in nature.
Most people are primarily visual.
There's an interesting study
that was published recently, just came out.
And that shows that actually memory and recall for material
that's consumed on a phone
is much lower than on the written page.
And there's an interesting reason that they give for this.
There could be a lot of reasons.
I just wanna point that out,
but they monitored breathing,
and they monitored heart rate,
and they monitored some other physiological signals
while people were either reading on a smartphone
or reading paper.
And what they found was that breathing
was essentially normal or equivalent in both conditions.
Meaning people breathe the same way,
whether or not they're reading on their smartphone
or reading from a written page.
But there was a particular category of breath
that was abolished by reading on the smartphone.
And this is what is referred to as physiological sighs.
I talk a lot about physiological sighs on the podcast
and my lab works on them.
This is a spontaneous innate pattern of breathing
that's governed by a little subset of neurons
in the brain stem,
for those you who wanna know,
this is a brain area called the parafacial nucleus,
discovered by Jack Feldman at UCLA,
who's the world expert in the neural mechanisms
of respiration.
And this low collection of neurons,
probably only a hundred neurons or so,
make sure that every three to five minutes
you do what's called the physiological side,
which is a very deep breath
sometimes followed by another short inhale.
So,
(Huberman breaths deeply)
and then a long exhale and the double deep breath
with a very deep breath reinflates
the little sacs in the lungs.
Your lungs aren't just two big bags of air,
they actually have hundreds of millions of little sacs
that we call the aveoli of the lungs.
And when you don't do these physiological sighs,
so in the second or third minute
after not having done a physiological sigh,
these little sacs collapse,
and they're kind of moist on the inside.
So you can imagine trying to blow open a balloon
that's moist on the inside.
You need a little bit of added air pressure.
And so the size reinflate those,
and then on the exhale allow you to offload carbon dioxide.
Now this happens even during sleep,
every three to five minutes,
and I've talked a lot about physiological sighs
as what I think is really a terrific realtime tool
for reducing anxiety and calming oneself down.
Indeed, it works very well.
We have a study that's out for review now,
is a collaborative work with David Spiegel and psychiatry,
but it points out that these physiological sighs
can be used double inhale through the nose,
long exhale through the mouth to calm down.
And it works very well because you offload carbon dioxide.
Now in this study about smartphone reading
versus reading on paper
what they found is that people stop engaging
in physiological sighs
anytime they're reading on the smartphone.
Now it wasn't a perfect study
because they probably also should had a tablet
and a laptop condition.
So it's not clear whether or not it's due only
to the reduced aperture of the visual window
that you're narrowing your attention,
and there's this sort of almost like an apnea,
a kind of starving of yourself or oxygen when you do this.
But it's very clear,
I mean, it's abundantly clear that two things,
one is nasal breathing
and that the other is getting sufficient oxygen to the brain
is important for comprehension.
So the takeaway from this is if ever possible,
try and read from a written page
or from a book or a piece of paper,
and if you can't do that,
then try and access whatever you're learning
from as large a screen as you can manage
in that particular environment.
And I do realize when people are commuting
and sometimes I'm guilty of looking at my phone,
and trying to read papers and passages on my phone.
But it's interesting because this study highlights
the linkage between this visual attention, our respiration,
and the fact that our body and our brain
have these innate mechanisms
for making sure that we're getting sufficient oxygen,
we're getting sufficient blood flow to the brain areas
that are required for learning.
And so again, I don't want to deemphasize the fact
that there is a lot of legitimate clinically
diagnosed ADHD out there,
but for a lot of people that are struggling with attention
or they feel like they just can't focus,
I think we all owe it to ourselves to ask,
"Well, what kind of environment am I creating for myself
that is depriving me of this focus?
And what simple things can I do
to try and enhance my ability of focus?"
Because I'm personally of the belief that if possible
and wherever it's not hazardous
to start with behavioral tools, right?
Before ever moving to supplementation
or prescription drugs, unless there's a real dire need,
I would think that behavioral tools
should be the most valuable
for the simple reason
that when you engage in a behavioral over and over again,
you get neuroplasticity,
your brain circuits change and get better.
Simply taking a drug or a supplement of any kind,
although they can have their value,
isn't going to rewire your brain in the ways that you want.
You're essentially dependent on that chemistry
in order to access the state that you want.
Right.
And the behavioral tools are gonna range from breath,
light exposure, nutrition, sleep, mindfulness, temperature,
all of these things that are becoming more and more
part and parcel of the neuroscience toolbox, right?
Like this field, which originated
from this perspective of let's understand the brain
as by necessity broadened to this mind body study
and trying to understand human biology more holistically.
Yeah, absolutely.
And I'm delighted that that's happening.
And I wanna point out that oftentimes
in the journey of teaching some of these tools
and sharing some of the science around breathwork,
or which is really respiration science
in the academic terms,
or about the role of temperature, or light,
people will quite understandably respond,
"Well, wait! This has been known about
for thousands of years."
Getting light in your eyes in the morning is useful,
these sorts of things, breathing in this way.
And I completely acknowledge that.
And my stance is that the communities
that have talked about these things for a number of years,
as well as the scientific community
are both guilty of the same thing,
which is hiding and disguising things
in very complicated language.
And so my goal is not to say,
"Oh, science is discovering these things,"
many of these things were discovered before,
but rather to put a language to them
that is neither cloaked in a mysticism,
nor is cloaked in scientific jargon.
That's really a key goal.
Because I think that we should all acknowledge
that many of these practices are quite useful
and we weren't really taught them in school,
and also mysticism is often a barrier
to a lot of these things becoming accessible.
So my hope is that the scientists
and the people from communities will sort of join hands
in trying to propagate these tools.
So yes, it's also amusing and exciting to me.
I mean, Stanford,
there's my group, neurobiology and ophthalmology,
there's David Spiegel's laboratory
that works on clinical applications of hypnosis
and mind body in the context of psychiatry.
So trauma, pain management,
and a huge number of other things, OCD, ADHD,
and Alia Crum's work over in psychology,
looking at belief effects and mind body.
She actually runs the mind body lab at Stanford,
does incredible work.
We can say that a few topics in particular
that were considered pretty fringy about 10 years ago,
I would say, breathwork was fringy
by the scientific community,
breathwork, the use of temperature
to access different bodily and brain states,
the gut microbiome,
and the fact that things like fiber and fermented foods
could be useful to us.
I think would've been kind of like scoffed at
and kind of choked off as like,
what is that a few years ago?
And then of course, there's a lot of excitement
about psychedelics a somewhat controversial area,
but now we can say that at Stanford,
Harvard, John Hopkins School of Medicine
and many other schools,
there are hundreds of laboratories working on these topics,
trying to figure out mechanism,
trying to figure out clinical applications.
And so it always raises this question of,
what's considered fringe now
it's very likely in 10 years
is going to be a major focus of lab laboratories.
And I also just want to give a kind of a shout out
to the National Institutes of Health,
has had an eye Institute, a cancer institute,
institutes for immunology,
there is now an Institute for Complimentary Health
and Medicine, NCCIH.
And they put a significant amount of tax dollars
to the study of the exact sort of things
we're discussing here.
Yeah. It's fascinating.
So many of these traditions emanate
from the traditions of yoga or Chinese medicine,
and are now getting validated through mechanistic study.
Yeah, that's pretty cool.
Sorry to interrupt.
I neglected to say Qiufu Mas lab at Harvard Medical School
is looking at the mechanisms underlying acupuncture
and has incredible studies published
in really top-tier journals,
finding that stimulation at one site in the body
can invoke heightened levels of inflammation,
which I think most people would wanna know about.
But I'm sure that the Chinese have known about this
for eons and yet stimulation elsewhere
can dramatically reduce inflammation,
but they're defining the mechanisms by which this happens,
release of epinephrine, adrenaline from the adrenals
or suppression of dopamine
released from one site in the body or from the brain.
And so by understanding mechanism,
I think that the scientific community
is going to be in a very good place
to improve on existing protocols,
validate many existing protocol,
and also there's a whole other reason
for us to be excited about this kind of thing happening,
which is that right now,
if you want your insurance to cover some of the things
that we're talking about, which can be very effective,
you're gonna have a hard time
convincing an insurance company
that they should support a hundred dollars a week,
respiration training or something,
if you don't already have
a serious clinically diagnosed apnea
or some other lung disorder.
In the near future,
there'll be mechanism scientific reports 2.2
in clinical trials that,
my hope is that insurance will start covering
a lot of these behavioral practices that are powerful,
not just because they work
but because they reshape the nervous system.
So that eventually
you don't have to rely on them as heavily,
which is the opposite
of a lot of prescription drugs out there.
And I'm in full support of prescription drugs
that can remedy,
I mean, people in suicidal depression
often need these things,
people with really bad cases of ADHD or OCD,
they sometimes really do need medication,
but for many people out there,
the way that they're struggling
can be remedied with behavioral tools.
So I'm just delighted that places like Stanford
are so supportive and other top institutions
are really getting behind this.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment
to talk to you about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to incorporate
more whole plants;
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet transformed my life
so profoundly,
and because I want everybody to experience some version
of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is the Plantpower Meal Planner,
our affordable all in one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off, in annual membership,
when you use the promo code RRhealth at checkout.
This is life changing stuff people,
for just a $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRhealth for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
In the COVID area where everybody was kind of forced
to retreat to their homes,
I know that your lab at Stanford
used that as an opportunity to start conducting studies
and using the fact that everybody was at home
as actually kind of an advantage
in studying some of the things that you're interested in.
So talk a little bit about that
and kind of what has you excited right now
among the things that you're looking at?
Yeah, so COVID presented a lot of challenges
and a lot of opportunities for science.
We were already set up and doing experiments on humans
in our lab, bringing them in,
putting them in virtual reality,
scaring them essentially,
looking at people who had anxiety
or clinically diagnosed anxiety,
and exploring how breathing and vision impact
those states of mine.
Going down underwater with Mueller,
and swimming with the sharks.
Right.
Which for some people was simply not scary
in our laboratory,
but we always find people's pain point one way or the other.
(both chuckling)
That work was published.
And I think laid down some of the groundwork
for what is the physiological signature
for what we call anxiety or fear
that hadn't really been addressed
in a realistic-ish format,
'cause it's been hard to study in the lab,
in virtual reality lab that to happen.
Then the pandemic hits and my lab had teamed up
with our Associate Chair of Psychiatry, Dr. David Spiegel,
who's the world expert in the clinical applications
of hypnosis.
I know hypnosis gets a little bit of a funny rap
because people think of it as stage hypnosis,
but really self-hypnosis,
very strongly clinically back studies from his lab,
showing what brain areas are activated
and deactivated under conditions of hypnosis.
And I wanted to join arms with David
because he has a real interest in mind body
and non-invasive tools for shaping the mind
to improve clinical syndromes,
but also for things like focus
and things like enhancing sleep and so on.
So what we did when the pandemic hit
was we got permission from our other colleague,
Alia Crum in psychology to equip a number of undergraduates,
but also people in the outside world with whoop bands
to evaluate things like heart rate, heart rate variability,
their sleep, et cetera,
and then we were in constant communication with them.
As they were binned into groups,
we had one group do a particular type of breathing
each day for five minutes a day,
another group,
different and do five minute breathwork pattern.
And then the fourth group I did mindfulness meditation
of a kind of traditional sort,
which is just really passively breathing,
however you're breathing,
but paying attention to that breathing.
The other breathwork
without getting into too much detail,
really centered on whether or not inhales
were more emphasized than exhales.
So one condition was cyclic sighing
of the sort that I talked about before.
So it's two inhales followed by an exhale,
two inhales followed by an exhale, but for five minutes,
which is a pretty long time to engage in that pattern,
but it's still a manageable period of time.
The other group did something that
was sort of akin to wim hof breathing,
which we call cyclic hyperventilation.
So deliberately for five minutes,
(Huberman breathing heavily)
really taking their body and brain into a heightened state
of arousal with some limited breath holds every so often.
And then we had another group
that did that sort of traditional box breathing,
inhale hold, exhale hold for equivalent amounts of time.
And the basic takeaway from this study
was that the cyclic sighing
led to a more dramatic calming
both within the breathwork session,
but also the ability to regulate one state
away from the breathwork session.
So people reported heightened sense of wellbeing,
reduced anxiety, improved sleep, lower resting,
heart rate overall.
And the reason we were able to get all those data
is because we were accessing them all the time,
24 hours a day.
So COVID shut down our ability
to bring people into the laboratory at that time,
but it opened up the opportunity for us to first of all,
study a much larger demographic than we would've otherwise,
not just Stanford students, not just people in the Bay Area,
but people all over the US.
For right now it's just been the US, not outside the US.
We also could monitor people different ages,
different backgrounds,
oftentimes harder to get to come to Stanford
directly in person,
but we could do that at scale at a distance.
And then of course, to monitor their data 24 hours a day,
and whoop was very generous in allowing us access
to the raw data.
So we weren't reliant on just the sleep scores within whoop,
we could get everything we wanted out of those data.
And so for us it represented a really powerful dataset,
and we're also delighted because NCCIH,
which is this complimentary health division of NIH.
They did not fund this study,
but they paid careful attention
to the fact that we and others started to do this.
And now NIH is starting to have specific calls
to action for funding science
that's done in the real world
and analyzed in labs at universities.
And of course there are limitations
to doing things this way,
but I found this to be incredibly interesting,
fun and informative.
And it really says to me that if you were going
to do a breathwork practice,
first of all, you don't need more than five minutes per day.
If you are going to select one breathwork practice,
cyclic sighing, this double inhales followed by exhales
for five minutes a day,
seems to have the greatest positive effect
on the greatest number of parameters.
And of course, there are other box breathing
is still useful, meditation is still useful;
we certainly found positive effects of those practices,
but it really points out the fact that
some of these innate patterns of breathing,
like cyclic sighing
that we do naturally every five minutes or so
can be sort of hijacked if you will,
and brought into a more condensed form
for five minutes a day.
And I think five minutes a day
is a pretty reasonable amount of time
to ask of oneself to do breathwork.
And I should say it didn't matter
if people did it early in the day or later in the day,
but the consistency was important.
And how significant was the state change
of that type of breathwork versus baseline
and also in comparison to the other varieties?
Yeah. Great question.
So during the actual breathwork session,
every group and including the meditation group
experienced a dramatic shift in their state.
For the sick like hyperventilation group,
they actually were ramped up more autonomic arousal.
You could think of that as more stress,
but as David Spiegel says,
it's not just the state you're in,
it's how you got there
and whether or not you had anything to do with it.
So when you are self-directing
an increase in autonomic arousal,
like getting into an ice bath, or charging up a hill,
or breathing really fast,
when you are doing that deliberately and you want to,
you generally associate that with a positive shift
in increased autonomic arousal.
When somebody else triggers that in you
or when event in the world triggers that in you,
then you generally say,
"Well, that was really stressful."
Which really speaks to the power of the prefrontal cortex,
our mind in interpreting these bodily states
that are exactly the same.
But to answer your question,
we always have this cutoff
of a P less than 0.05 statistically significant differences.
So they could not be attributed to chance.
The cyclic sighing condition did lead to,
I would say a near doubling of the positive effects
compared to the others,
but all four groups displayed positive shifts
compared to what was at baseline essentially.
Now it's very hard to have a pure control condition
in something like this.
'Cause if you tell people just sit quietly for five minutes,
it is its own sort of form of mindfulness and stillness.
So control conditions in these sorts of studies
are a little bit complicated.
Our next step is to get people into brain scanners
to really understand what is changing at the neural level
in the short term and the long term.
And that's actually where Spiegel's group
has done this incredible work on hypnosis,
showing that when people go into states of self-hypnosis
there are signature shifts
in what they call the default mode network.
How the brain is idling the different brain areas
that are active and the ability to control context,
which has a lot to do with focus.
And we could talk about hypnosis if you like,
although he'd be better suited to tell...
Yeah, no, that was my next thing.
I wanna better understand the Spiegel version of hypnosis
versus the spinning pinwheel version
that we all conjure in our minds,
like explain what that is
and how that's becoming this tool for scientific study.
Yeah.
Well, so this is David Spiegel's work
and he has an interesting story.
His father was actually a psychiatrist and hypnotist.
And his father learned about hinosis and incorporated it
into his psychiatric practice based on a mentor that he had.
So this is often how things are handed down in medicine.
And so David learned it from his father.
And I should say that the effects of clinical hypnosis
are very robust.
Incredible success with things like smoking cessation,
incredible success with pain reduction,
50 to 80% reductions in chronic pain,
outcomes in cancer even probably
due to the negative effects of chronic stress
on cancer outcomes by reducing stress, trauma and so forth.
So basically what Spiegel and his father developed
was a assay, sort of what we call a curbside assay
for determining whether or not someone
has a high, medium, or low degree of hypnotizability.
And this brings us back to the visual system.
The neurons in the brain stem that control eye movements,
they have a relationship
either to the aspect of the nervous system
that's associated with alertness or with calmness.
And not surprisingly,
when people look up when the eyes are directed upward,
that's actually in the neural pathways
associated with alertness.
When they look downward or close their eyelids,
those are associated with the neural pathways
associated with calmness and sleep.
Which is kind of a dough when you hear it.
So like when you get tired,
you kind of put your chin down, when you close your eyes.
When you're wide awake,
you tend to be eyes up and eyes really wide.
Recalling of course,
that your eyes are the two pieces of your brain
that happen to be outside your cranial vault
and the only two pieces of your brain
outside your cranial vault.
So when you see eyes, those are two pieces of brain,
which is just to underscore
why they're so powerfully reflective
of what's going on deeper in the brain.
So when people can look this up online,
it sounds a little wacky,
but there's something called the Spiegel eye roll test,
which is not the teen eye roll
that's usually associated with a different kind of sigh.
I'm familiar with that one.
(both laughing)
We've all done it or experienced it.
So basically you can assess how hypnotizable somebody is
by having them look up.
I can actually do with you right now.
And again, I'm hijacking David's tool,
so you can look up towards the ceiling
and then while maintaining upward gaze,
slowly close your eyelids.
Okay.
So you were able to just shut your eyelids down,
and you can open your eyes now.
And so what I observed was,
as soon as you brought your eyelids down,
your eyes also move towards me and your eyelids shut.
Now I'm very hypnotizable,
and there's a little bit of a bias demonstration
because I'm trying to illustrate the differences.
But I fall at the very far end of the scale
on high-hypnotizability,
where when I look up and then...
I don't wanna go into hypnosis, then I close my eyes.
The whites of my eyes should still be exposed
for a second before...
In other words,
you're able to maintain your pupils focused upward
as you're closing your eyes.
Right.
And the reason this test was developed to be clear,
'cause I realized this is probably all sounding
a little bit wacko to people.
The reason that this was developed
is that there's a known role
of particular cranial nerves, okay?
Three, four, and seven,
as well as some other cranial nerves,
one set of cranial nerves directs the eyes upward
and is associated with alertness.
The other set of cranial nerves directs the eyes downwards
associated with closing of the eyelid.
So these are two competing circuits.
People who are very capably of being hypnotized,
tend to be able to maintain activation
of both circuits simultaneously,
which will make sense for what I'm gonna say next,
which is that hypnosis is really a state of deep calm,
yet high degree of focused and limited context.
So we remember that autonomic seesaw
that we're either asleep or panicked, drowsy or alert,
and in waking state like you are in now
probably more towards alert
but calm kind of the seesaw is even.
So this is almost a an unusual bending of the seesaw
in a way that you're both very relaxed and very alert
and context is limited by whatever the hypnotist says.
Now in clinical hypnosis,
the goal is to get the person
to self-direct their own mental changes.
Whereas in stage hypnosis, the goal is exactly the same;
bring people into a state of very calm,
but narrow context and increased focus,
but the hypnotist is interested
in directing the person's actions and states.
So that's the key distinction.
And I think that clinical hypnotists like Spiegel and others
who are also world certified physicians and psychiatrists,
but I think all clinical hypnotists,
they look at stage hypnosis as kind of the...
They don't like it so much
because it detracts from the power of this thing
that we call hypnosis and people get distracted
by the fact that people can be inspired to do things
that they wouldn't otherwise.
So in a clinical hypnosis session,
Spiegel or someone else would bring you in,
you do this test,
you would probably fall into the category
of low to moderate hypnotizability,
that might rule you out,
but for most people they're going to be moderate
to high levels of hypnotizability.
And then there would be some discussion
while you were in this state of hypnosis
where the clinician would encourage you
to think about certain aspects of whatever it is
that you're dealing with.
So maybe it was problems with focus
and they would have you visualize to spotlights
and bringing them together.
Maybe it would be two focus on something
that really bothers you quite a lot
and the bodily sensations,
and then to dissociate those bodily sensations.
And the degree of positive clinical outcomes using hypnosis,
again, are just remarkable.
If people wanna try this there is an app,
I can mention with that Spiegel
has developed on the basis of the clinical data
and a lot of scientific studies
exploring the brain areas that are activated.
It's called Reveri, R-E-V-E-R-I.
I should mention it,
it does now sit behind a paywall,
but I think you get a seven day free trial.
And it's right now only available for Apple,
but I'm told that they're gonna have it for Android as well.
And there are other clinical tools for hypnosis.
I've personally found hypnosis to be very valuable
for enhancing my ability to get into sleep.
And for any time that I'm dealing with a problem
that I can't seem to solve simply by talking, running
and a couple good night's sleep
or any kind of cathartic behavior that I'm might attempt.
So there's a lot there
and there's a lot more to be said about that,
and maybe Spiegel should step in at some point
and join the conversation.
But I think that hypnosis is really a wonderful example
of how vision can allow one
to assess whether or the brain
can shift state easily or not.
It certainly involves narrowing of visual fields
in order to anchor focus,
and there's also a respiration component.
Almost always in hypnosis
the hypnotist will encourage the person
to take a deep breath as they close their eyes
and to then imagine floating and being in a state of calm.
And the bigger theme here,
perhaps the most important theme is that neuroplasticity,
the brain and nervous system's ability to change
in response to experience really is a two part process.
The first part of that process
always involves focus and attention.
Especially as an adult,
you simply cannot learn unless you are focused
on what you want to learn.
We know this.
As a kid, there's a bit more passive learning.
But as an adult, unless it's a negative event,
which tends to automatically recruit your focus, right?
The hot stove, the horrible experience, the car crash,
the trauma of any kind,
which immediately grabs all your attention,
you have to direct your attention.
And then the second part of neuroplasticity
'cause it is indeed a process is periods of deep rest.
It is during periods of sleep
and what we call non-sleep deep rest
that the neural circuits themselves change and rewire.
Hypnosis seems to incorporate both the focus
and the relaxation
in a way that accelerates neuroplasticity.
And so while it might seem kind of mystical,
or wacky, or crazy, it makes perfect sense
as to why this would be.
It grabs both states of autonomic arousal,
high degree of focus and arousal
and high degree of relaxation
and it compacts them into a single routine.
But in the context of a clinical hypnosis session,
the kind of direction that's being given the patient
is to disassociate with the neural groove or whatever,
like let's say, they're trying to quit smoking.
Like what is the process of untangling that knot
so that you can create this new behavior pattern.
Okay. Yeah.
Very astute of you because it highlights a conundrum
that the field of neuroscience,
and psychiatry, and psychology has.
And indeed that all of wellness and high performance has,
which is on the one hand you could imagine
that the way to shift one's brain and body
around a traumatic event or some challenge
would be to really fully embody
all the emotions and bodily sensations of that thing,
and then over time, desensitize yourself.
So that's one form of gradual dissociation
from at least the emotional component of something.
You could also imagine that the goal is to split those off
at the outset.
And I'll just mention,
we hear nowadays a lot about a FDA approved therapy
which is ketamine therapy.
Ketamine is a dissociative anesthetic.
It's being used to treat depression and trauma.
This is kept in emergency rooms,
now this is in widespread use.
Work from my colleague called (indistinct) lab at Stanford
has shown the precise neural networks in the brain
that are activated by ketamine in an animal model,
but also in humans.
And it's very clear that it causes this dissociative state.
It actually uncouples brain areas
that normally would be coupled.
And so you think,
"Well, that's weird,
I thought that in order to heal trauma,
you're supposed to go into the trauma
and then reduce the amount of emotion."
But in these ketamine induced states,
people actively report things like,
"I was watching myself,"
third person in myself, "Go through the experience,"
which is exactly what you hear about people
who went through a trauma,
things like sexual trauma, like rapes, people say,
I was floating above my body
and could see it happening as somebody else.
Many of the therapies designed to treat trauma
are exactly the sort of dissociative process
that is occurring during the trauma.
So I don't have an answer as to why those treatments
can work despite embodying the same kind of approach
that happened during the trauma.
What does seem to be the case
is that accessing the state of mind that was occurring
during the trauma, or during anxiety, or insomnia, or pain,
and then third personing that experience
and being able to imagine a different bodily
or mental response seems to be the common theme
through all treatments for trauma, fear, anxiety, et cetera.
And the additional requirement,
however, is that it's not sufficient
to just cognitively rehearse it.
There needs to be a shift in bodily state
and almost always what threads through all these therapies
like ketamine therapy or any kind of,
even cathartic therapy is that at some point
the patient or the person needs to access a state
of self-directed deep calm.
And so there are versions of hypnosis,
for instance, if you're dealing with a particular problem,
you imagine the problem on our left screen,
this is under hypnosis,
and a left panel and then you write out in your mind
the possible alternate responses on the right panel,
you grow the size of that and reduce the size of the other,
might sound like, why would that work?
But under conditions where the total context of the mind
is set to that process,
and you're not even aware of anything else
going on in the room,
that seems to accelerate the neuroplasticity
and allows people to actually do that in real life
out of hypnosis.
It's super fascinating.
I mean, it's crazy to me
to hear about the therapeutic applications of ketamine,
because my association with that is being in treatment
with people that use that.
Like I knew one guy who jumped off his roof.
Oh, yeah.
Ketamine, that drug is no joke.
It's cool that they're finding these ways
of applying it in in a context like this,
but yeah, like buyer beware, I suppose too,
these are controlled environments obviously.
Absolutely.
And even though they are controversial
one can't help but notice the work of,
for instance, Matthew Johnson,
who's at Johns Hopkins School of Medicine,
and he's looking at macro dose psilocybin
for the treatment of trauma and depression.
And I've talked to Matt directly and I said,
what is the key element of a successful therapeutic session?
Because he was telling me,
one person is having one experience,
another person's having another experience.
So there's nothing to anchor this.
And he said, it's the quote unquote,
"Letting go and allowing their autonomic arousal
to be taken over by something else."
And I thought, well, the data are pretty impressive,
but that's the exact opposite of what we're talking about
in terms of ketamine type therapies.
I think hypnosis kind of resides in the middle
in that it involves going into the state
that creates the anxiety, trauma or pain,
and then actively dissociating from that state
in a way that you actively replace it with another state.
Psychedelic therapies are still very poorly understood.
One of the things that I think is important to emphasize is,
we always hear such and such opens plasticity,
such and such...
Plasticity is a process like digestion
or something like that.
You don't necessarily want to open plasticity
because all sorts of things can happen in there.
And I'm aware of people that have benefited tremendously
from psychedelic therapies,
I'm also aware of people that have suffered tremendously
from psychedelic therapies.
And I have a colleague at Stanford also in psychiatry,
whose name is Nolan Williams.
He does transcranial magnetic stimulation.
He's an expert and a researcher and clinician
in understanding depression and tools to explore that.
And he has studies that he's performing now
looking at the brains of people
who have undergone different forms of psychedelic therapies
with no bias whatsoever
as to whether or not they're beneficial or not,
but really to highlight the individual differences
before, not during,
but then after the psychedelic therapies.
And so I think there's still a lot to be learned.
I mean, as much as we understand mechanisms and brain areas,
and there's some successes out there
and some failures out there in psychiatry and neuroscience,
I mean, we're still groping around in the dark
more or less in terms of figuring out
like what these compounds do.
And a big effort in large part
led by a group up at UC Davis.
Some people are gonna be dismayed by this,
but a big effort is being made to take these drug compounds,
remove the hallucinogenic components from them
and ask whether or not there are other aspects
to their biology that have nothing to do
with hallucinating or the letting go,
or the other aspects of psychedelic journeys
in order to figure out whether or not
something else in those compounds
is allowing the brain to readjust itself.
Yeah, interesting.
Right?
Because there are a lot of variables
in a psychedelic journey.
It's not necessarily the case that the hallucination
or the disruption of time and space
is the thing that's rewiring the brain.
So there's a lot to be learned.
Take the fun out of it.
Yeah. For some people.
Although I do think it will make it more accessible
for people who are averse to the idea of losing control.
And so I'm excited by all these things.
I certainly don't wanna encourage
on a maverick use of these things,
many of the them are still scheduled drugs
so they can land you in jail, right?
I think hypnosis at least for me
lands in a category of interesting and intriguing
for people to explore.
It's certainly non-invasive.
You would definitely wanna work
with somebody very, very good
who also has some clinical training in dealing with trauma,
who also has some clinical training
in dealing with whatever it is that people are dealing with
because there's been success with eating disorders,
which are very, very challenging in the abs,
even with medication, those can be very, very challenging.
ADHD and some of the other clinical syndromes.
Well, the broadening of neuroscience
to kind of include psychiatry and psychology,
I think is super interesting.
And this idea of how we're approaching
the processing of things like trauma
through dissociative practices is super interesting
because we've always thought of dealing with our past
through a kind of talk therapy modality,
which by definition requires
that we confront some aspect of our past
or something that we've repressed.
And of course,
that's gonna bring up all types of powerful feelings
and you have to feel those feelings,
but you also have to understand that feelings are out facts
and the only way to kind of get to the other side,
and kind of withdraw the charge
that those past events have on
how you think about yourself and behave in the world
is to create that disassociation, right?
So how does that...
Let's just kind of focus on trauma right now,
because I think it's super important.
everybody has their past trauma and those traumas
are very powerful as predictors of current
and future behavior.
Yeah.
I mean, if ever there was a phenomenon in life
that I'm struck by it's trauma
and it's incredible to me
how we experience these things
for some people more than others, right?
To some extent everyone has trauma,
to some extent I think we need to be fair
and say that some people have a tremendous amount of trauma
and other people less.
But that there's some consistent themes
that the psychoanalyst actually had right.
Which is that for many people, there's this,
what the analyst would call a repetition compulsion, right?
Somebody experiences something really terrible as a child
and then as an adult they find themselves seeking out
similar types of situations.
And it's just the most illogical thing one can imagine.
And the analyst would say,
well, this is a reparative wish,
an attempt to throw oneself back subconsciously,
throw oneself back into these scenarios
to get a different outcome.
Right.
So for example, if you had a deadbeat dad,
you're a young woman,
you're gonna seek out a boyfriend
who has those same behavior patterns.
(indistinct chatters)
Defies logic.
Yeah. In one case, it's the exact opposite.
In which case we might say,
well, that's a more functional step,
in the other case it's,
yeah, it's this repetition compulsion
making the same mistakes despite knowing better, right?
And not necessarily from this standpoint of addiction
where there are some deeper dopamine circuits driving that.
So trauma is fascinating in that way.
I mean, what do we know about trauma?
And again, I'm borrowing from some of my conversations
with David Spiegel and with Anna Lamche
who I know you've had on the podcast.
It's very clear that relief from trauma in some way
or another almost always involves going
deliberately bringing oneself back into the state of mind
and body that occurred during the trauma,
as horrible as that might seem
avoiding that seems to be an issue.
And then gradually or hopefully quickly,
but in some cases, gradually desensitizing oneself
to that experience
as not just a overwhelming, horrible experience,
but a sad but no longer overwhelming experience.
So that they can gain some sort of ability
to think inside of the memory,
and to parse what happened.
One resounding theme that I've collected
in talking to trauma therapists
and exploring a lot of therapies for trauma
is that oftentimes trauma involves a deep confusion
for whatever reason,
a deep confusion about who was responsible.
And this is something that's somewhat complicated
and can be troubling to think about,
but people will experience a trauma;
a car crash, a sexual assault,
a devastating financial loss can also be a trauma,
and then somehow in one's mind,
it's not clear whether or not
that was something that happened to them
or that they created for themselves.
Now, the typical script of this
was people talking about,
"Oh, I shouldn't have been out that late,
or dressed that way, or acted that way,"
but it's actually can be much more subtle
and diabolical than that.
It can start to route into people's own percept of self.
Maybe I'm not worthy of being happy,
and therefore the fact that this happened makes total sense.
People create these crazy scripts
and crazy because they don't match any real world facts,
but they do match a lot of internal structure.
And so it becomes very complex to unpack all this.
But what we know for sure is that accessing
the state of mind and body
that resembles the state of mind and body during the trauma
is the first step in moving trauma out of the body,
so-called trauma release.
Now, almost always that has to be done in concert
with a really well trained physician or clinician
because that can be overwhelming
certainly the first time.
There's also some evidence
based on some decent studies
that show that deliberately accessing states
of high autonomic arousal
that are independent from the trauma.
So things like ice baths, things like hard exercise,
things like very, very intense experiences
separate from the traumatic memory
can be useful in allowing people
to attain comfort at high levels
of autonomic arousal, right?
I mean, you're trying to essentially say,
go back to this place and work it through,
try and get some space or some distance from the emotion
and yet for some people
just an elevation in heart rate is overwhelming for them.
And so they're not even gonna set foot
on the first step up the mountain
when in fact that's exactly what they need to do.
So there's now a kind of movement in psychiatry
and psychology to bring in more of these,
I guess you could call them somatic approaches.
But to my mind, they're really physiological approaches.
They're really approaches that teach people
how to be tolerant of high levels of autonomic arousal.
And so that's something that we're starting to see
a shift in.
The other thing I should just acknowledge is that
until the psychoanalyst,
the cognitive behavioral therapists,
the neuroscientists and the psychiatrist join arms,
we are going to go around and around and around
this merry go round of not knowing
how to deal with trauma and feelings, right?
I mean, we're all told to feel our feelings,
but not trust them as facts.
And yet, here I'm telling you
that most successful trauma therapies
involve getting right up close to that event,
really letting it almost overtake oneself,
and then start to create these gaps.
And these gaps that I'm referring to
are real gaps in neural circuitry.
The work from Spiegel and many others has shown,
and the work doing brain imaging
under conditions of ketamine
and other types of pharmacologic therapies
has shown that there are active associations
normally between the prefrontal cortex,
which is thinking, planning and reasoning,
the insular, which is an area of the brain
that monitors how we feel internally,
and then some of these areas
like the anterior singlet cortex,
which are involved in kind of self-monitoring
and figuring out how much of what I'm experiencing
is coming from thoughts and things within
and from things in my environment.
And under conditions of extreme autonomic arousal,
and somewhat counterintuitively
under conditions of deep relaxation,
those neural circuits are able to rearrange themselves.
And when one emerges from those treatments,
the default network then is one of perspective.
It's one of saying, "
"Ah, this is something that happened,
but it was not my fault,"
or, "This is something that happened
and indeed it set me up
for a number of positive opportunities in my life."
All those sorts of stories that we hear about all the time.
So if this is sounding a little bit abstract,
I'm trying my best to put some structure on it,
but where there's a lack of structure
I'll kind of wriggle out of that
by saying that there is no clear answer
as to where trauma is represented in the nervous system.
Many people talk about trauma being manifest
as physical symptoms in their body,
and that used to be considered kind of pseudoscience,
makes perfect sense,
makes perfect sense.
After all the nervous system is the brain,
the eyes and the spinal cord for central nervous system,
and then every organ in your body
is innovated by nerve cells, neurons,
and the peripheral nervous system.
So the manifestation of things in the body and in the brain
shouldn't surprise anybody.
And I think one of the great expansions of neuroscience
in the last few years is that whereas five/10 years ago,
you would find very few grants funding work in laboratories
and laboratories working on elements of the neurosystem
in the body.
Very, very few.
Maybe 98% of the focus was on things within the brain,
memory, consciousness, vision hearing, et cetera.
Now an enormous number of laboratories
are moving into this mind body relationship,
but they don't call it that,
they call it the peripheral nervous system,
the autonomic nervous system, right?
They call it the gut brain axis, right?
So we have fancy names to disguise the fact
that we're studying mind and body.
Right.
God forbid.
Anybody find out.
What's interesting about the trauma discussion is,
when I think about it,
I think of trauma being just an extreme example
of not just something that happened to you,
but a story we tell about who we are, like what we are,
what we were talking about this the other day.
We all walk around looping some narrative in our minds
about who we are, what we're capable of,
what happened to us, why we are the way we are.
And I think we cause ourselves a lot of suffering
and undue pain as a result of narratives
that are really detached from reality
whether positive or negative.
They take on a life of their own
and they're very real to us
and yet if you put them under the microscope
and deconstruct them, they actually generally don't hold up.
So from a neurochemistry, neurobiology point of view,
how do you think about this
and how can you talk about empowering people
to deconstruct those narratives
and hopefully create healthier versions of them?
Yeah.
Well, the stability of self is a very mysterious
but very pervasive theme in neuroscience.
I mean, you wake up every day
and depending on how you feel about yourself
you might feel better or worse,
but you're you every day, you recognize yourself.
But what is you?
And how malleable is your default personality?
Well, what is you is,
I mean, that's certainly not gonna be anchored
in one brain area.
We know this.
There's gonna be a network of activity.
There are cases of course, of multiple personality
and things of that sort,
but exceedingly rare.
Our self percept is often very different
than other people's perception of us.
Say, I don't want to out him,
but we have a member of our podcast team
who to me is just like the calmest person in the world
and he manages an incredibly complicated life
with immense grace.
He's extremely talented in his work.
He's just an incredible human being.
But if you ask him a bit more about his internal world,
if he's feeling like he wants to share,
but he'll say, yeah, internally,
it's just chatter, there's tons going on,
but externally I experience him
as the one of the calmest people I know.
And I think a lot of people see themselves
or feel themselves as anxious when in reality
the way they emerge in the real world
is very, very different from their internal percept.
So that's a first thing to recognize.
Conversing a lot of people who think they're incredible
might not be perceived as incredible.
And we could have a whole conversation about narcissists
some other time, because that's a real thing, right?
I mean, narcissists exploit the reactions of other people
and the commitments and allegiances
or lack of allegiances of other people
in order to feed this very squishy internal ego, right?
That they have.
Their self-concept is actually very weak
but they come across often as very dominant and in control.
And we're getting better at recognizing
who those people are
and the interesting thing is they probably don't realize
that they are the way they are,
just by the thousands if not tens of thousands of videos
about narcissists on YouTube and elsewhere.
So narcissist aside.
The reality is that much of how we are gauged
in terms of who we are is on our behavior
and how calm people perceive us to be
or how stressed people perceive us to be
in a bunch of different contexts.
And that's actually one of the major ways
that we just sort of assess
whether or not somebody would be a useful partner
or somebody to know in one situation or another
in many situations.
We're very good at subconsciously
perceiving other people's level of autonomic arousal
through things like pupil dilation.
I'm talking a lot now,
so I might be more flush than usual,
but it's contextual, right?
It's contextual, we're here and we're talking a lot.
So you also gain knowledge over time
and you realize that,
"Ah, when this person is in this situation,
they occupy this kind of level of arousal in that situation,
that level arousal and so on."
So in terms of our concept of others,
I think that gaining we're a lot of knowledge
about the brain areas,
for instance, incredible work
from Nancy Kanwisher's lab at MIT,
we have what's called the fusiform face area,
literally a little catalog or library
of neurons in your brain.
This fusiform gyrus area of your brain
that recognizes faces with exquisite precision.
I mean, any number people can walk into the room
and you'll know who they are, or if you don't know them.
So facial recognition,
even when people are in profile
or you see the back of their head,
so it's not even a face,
face recognition in old world primates of which we are
there's incredible machinery there.
Very little is understood about self-perception
and where self-perceptions reside.
But most people can recognize themself in the mirror
and that occurs from a very early age.
So I'd be willing to speculate
that a lot of what we perceive about ourself
and the stability of our self-perception
has a lot to do with our visual images of ourself
and people's reactions to us.
So we're cataloging all those data all the time.
Now, how malleable is it?
Well, I mean, last time we sat down
for a recorded discussion,
we talked about how...
I was really emphasizing actions first
as a way to shift perception sensations and emotions.
And I still stand behind that
because that's the accessible form of neuroplasticity
for most of us.
Actions change your nervous system over time.
And if ever there was a truth in neurosciences
that the nervous system can change in response to experience
the more heightened or critical that experience is,
the faster those changes are going to occur.
So that just leads me to a place where I'd say,
how crucial is it to change one's behavior
and therefore one's identity is probably going to dictate
whether or not you're able to do it or not.
I think about that show, "Madman,"
where he basically takes on a completely different life
and persona, and he was able to maintain that
and this secret that he was actually somebody else
for a long enough period of time,
but it's through behaviors that people gauge us
and then we start to gauge ourself.
Sure.
So it's actions if you wanna transcend
whatever loop you're in,
you start behaving in contrast or whatever that narrative is
until your nervous system kind of cottons onto that
and it becomes more habitual.
But the ultimate question of course,
would be if somebody just started behaving
in complete contraposition
to their entire personality,
started talking about the opposite of the ideas
that they believe in and start behaving on that,
could you just completely transcend your personality
and become another individual altogether personality-wise?
Yeah, I believe that's probably possible.
It's wild.
It's really wild.
And it really speaks to the fact that the nervous system
is paying attention to its own actions.
It's kind of a case of cognitive dissonance.
And it's what your actions do in some sense define you
both to people outside of you and to oneself.
There's this concept in psychoanalysis of the interject,
which I find fascinating.
The interject is this idea that we can subconsciously embody
the reactions of somebody else.
So one thing that fascinates me
now that I'm a bit more involved
in sort of online interactions and social medias,
there's tremendous number
of really inspiring people out there.
I put you in this category,
I'll put you on the spot and embarrass you,
but I read your book long before we met
and was really motivated
to make a number of important changes in my life
on the basis of reading that book.
I truly was.
And so just to embarrass you a bit here,
but that's the (indistinct)
No, I'm gonna get flush.
Yeah, appropriately.
Yeah, 'cause it's an incredible journey.
And, or last time we talked about David Goggins,
and there are many examples, right?
You can go online now and see examples
of incredible people doing incredible things.
Now, one version of that is to think,
"Oh, that's inspiring."
It shifts my autonomic arousal
so I can get up at 4:30 in the morning,
like Jocko and like get after it and do this stuff.
Which, and frankly,
there've been times when I'll see a social media post
and I'm like, "Yeah, I'm being lazy,
I should really push a little harder."
Or you had Chad Wright on here.
Right.
He and I are very different in a variety of ways
and we've never met.
But I find his content in incredibly inspiring
because the way that he communicates his conviction,
even though some of my convictions are different than his.
And I learned about him through you.
So we could consider that inspiration,
but then the idea of the analyst that I think is appropriate
and keep in mind that while Freud,
there were many issues with him and Young and analysis,
they did have a heavy interest in physiology
as the root of the subconscious.
And there's this idea of the interject is fascinating to me
because what it says is that,
if you consume enough of that content,
if you read enough books about people
who have embarked on certain kinds of journeys
and made certain choices,
that at some point you might interject
some of their personality and their responses
and subconsciously start making decisions,
hopefully positive decisions on your own behalf.
Maybe having more appropriate boundaries,
maybe taking better self care or care of other people,
and that without even realizing it
you're starting to make better choices on your own behalf,
and then at some point you move from the interject
to a recognition that,
"Wait, it was me that made that change.
I'm the one that managed to get up a bit earlier
and do a little bit more or to be kinder in this context,
or to listen a little bit better in this context."
And over time, we start to ascribe those changes to ourself.
So this is a more gradual shift in personality
and this story of who one is,
but I think it's a powerful one
and I like it because we hear so much today
about the negativity that's out there
and how to navigate the just onslaught of negative news
and negative interactions online.
And for that reason,
I really make an effort to really focus
on kind of the bright shining lights out there.
Because I do think that the information that we consume
sets the internal context of our subconscious
and sets the internal context
for what we decide to do consciously.
And in many ways, it's sort of like garbage-in-garbage-out.
And if it's positive stories and inspiration in
that's how you're basically gonna react in the world.
So I think that the nervous system
has a tremendous capacity to learn consciously
and subconsciously.
And after all it is during sleep
that our nervous system rewires.
We know that the dreaming that occurs
during rapid eye movement sleep
has this very unique signature
of being very emotionally salient;
falling, being chased, et cetera,
but that the body is incapable
of releasing adrenaline, epinephrine during that time.
So it's its own sort of form of trauma therapy, right?
So that's a subconscious learning
that we go through each night
provided we're getting into rapid eye movement sleep.
So the brain is designed to access these states in sleep
that help us rewire in beneficial ways.
If you want, I don't recommend it,
you can run the other experiment,
sleep deprive yourself for three nights
and see how your emotionality is doing, right?
Yeah. That's super interesting.
I mean, I think ultimately though
it always goes back to action.
You can consume a tremendous amount
of inspirational content and then convince yourself
that you did something productive,
or you feel better about yourself
without having ever actually done anything.
And I see a lot of that as well,
but ultimately at some point you would think
that that's gonna translate
into some kind of action or behavior.
One would hope.
And that brings up kind of these ideas
around alter ego, right?
If you feel yourself
not worthy of being that type of person,
you see Jocko, he's waking up at 4:30 in the morning
and doing what he does and you say,
"Well, what would Jocko do?"
And then you do that.
You kind of step into the alter ego of Jocko
and what he would do and start mimicking that behavior,
over time then you said,
you wake up and you realize like,
"Oh, it's me.
I can shed that alter ego now,
and I can kind of own this space for myself."
Yeah. It exactly.
And I think that one of the hardest things to do
is to calibrate one's consumption of social media
or any kind of high potency information.
I mean, if you think about it,
this is the first time in human history
that you can scroll through 50 movies in one minute.
I mean if a picture is worth a thousand words, right?
We know that a movie is worth 10,000 pictures.
I mean, the visual system loves motion.
And so I'm sure the algorithms reflect this.
And so really setting constraints
on the amount of interaction with stuff is important.
And I think setting constraints
on what type of information you're going to consume.
I mean, there is something about our nervous system
that draws us to look at the car crash,
to click behind that muted screen
that allows you to see the gory thing
or to get involved
in some sort of a very narrow context online argument.
I mean, everyone is prone to that.
Some people more than others,
but there's also a lot of incredible content out there.
And I think that the high potency positive content,
whatever that means,
for some people that's listening
to a piece of classical music,
these days I'm really interested
in finding a lot of incredible artwork online
and just going,
"Wow, people are creating some amazing stuff."
That can be inspiring.
So it comes in a variety of different forms
for different people, but being very,
I think that we all need to be more guarded
of the kinds of information in the context
that we expose our nervous systems to,
and the problem with social media to just acknowledge it
is that it's a free for all in terms of context.
And you can set limits on it in time,
but you can't set limits on it in terms of context at all
unless you're very, very good at self governing
or governing the use of social media in kids, for instance.
I mean, the just endless fire hose of stimulation
that you can expose your neurochemistry to is unprecedented.
We're not wired for that.
I can't imagine that being impulsed so vociferously,
so continually in the way that we are
is doing anything good for us.
That seems to be the study, right?
That needs to be done on,
what is this crazy mass experiment that we're running
on the human brain right now?
Yeah.
Well, I think it brings us back
to this issue of brain states.
We, meaning neuroscience,
certainly not my work, but Matt Walker and others,
William Dement at Stanford,
who defined rapid eye movement sleep,
although he didn't discover it, he helped define it.
They successfully defined the major stages
or states of sleep, slow wave sleep,
rapid eye movement sleep, alternating in 90 minute cycles,
more or less, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
When we dream, when we have emotional dreams, muscle repair,
growth hormone, all that stuff,
we have very poor definition of waking states.
We just don't even know what to call them.
We call them flow, or focused, or happy, or sad,
but a lot of those are emotional labels
and kind of subjective labels
that have some degree of kind of grading to them like,
"Oh, that was a good state, or a bad state,
or a happy state."
We have not yet defined most waking states.
We hear about alpha waves, gamma waves, et cetera,
but that's very crude.
For people that don't know,
the brain waves are generally measured by e.g,
these skull cups that are non-invasive
with a bunch of electrodes.
Terrific, because you can do this anywhere
without drilling through the skull,
terrible, because they only measure activity
in the outer centimeter or so of the brain.
So they're not telling you a whole lot
about what's happening.
It's like looking at the ocean,
the waves on the ocean
trying to figure out what's happening at depth.
It's just not gonna work.
So we need to better define waking brain states.
However, one thing that's clear from the work on sleep
that's now working its way into the naming
and understanding of brain states and wakefulness
is that one state precedes another.
Now your bike ride where you're listening to the audio book
is a way in which you're coordinating
your respiration physiology or breathing,
and your motor output, your bike riding
with the ability to access auditory information
and remember it well.
So you figured out something about that state,
but the neuroscientist in me says,
okay, but what follows that state when you get back?
What state are you in then?
Is it a state of exhaustion
that allows you to go into deep depress
to access neuroplasticity
or is it a state of where you've essentially moved
all that excess autonomic arousal out of your body
and now finally you can sit down
and just focus your cone of attention on your work?
So one state proceeds another.
And one thing that I think can be incredibly useful
to people would be to think about two hallmarks
of brain states in order to access them more readily.
One is that the thing that we are all a slave to,
all of us is the 24 hour circadian cycle.
Every cell in our body has a 24 hour clock
that runs at the level of genes,
and the level of cellular processes
and every network in our body,
whether or not it's nervous system,
spleen, whatever is governed by this 24 hour clock.
We can fairly crudely but still accurately subdivide
that 24 hour period into three phases.
What I would call phase one,
and I'm just naming it phase one,
'cause we don't have a better name for it
is from about zero until about eight or nine hours
after you wake up.
Phase two is from about nine hours after you wake up
until about 16 hours after you've woken up.
And phase three would be from about 17 hours to 24 hours.
The 17 hour to 24 hour period that we're calling phase three
is sleep.
And we know what we should be doing in that state.
We should be accessing as much uninterrupted,
deep sleep as we can,
and the beautiful work that Matt's done and others have done
says, okay, lower the temperature in the room,
elevate your feet a little bit, et cetera, et cetera.
Keep it dark.
I mean, there's a lot of things
that we could talk about there.
Phase one and phase two,
we know based on really good neuroscience
have certain signature patterns of neurotransmitter release
and autonomic arousal that lend themselves better
to certain activities,
both mental and physical and not others.
So phase one, for instance,
is always accompanied by an increase in cortisol.
This is a healthy release of cortisol.
A stress hormone that wakes us up.
It's part of the wake up system.
And the release of epinephrine,
which is also called adrenaline
and the molecule of dopamine.
It turns out epinephrine and dopamine,
dopamine actually manufactures epinephrine.
They're biochemically.
So that phase one of the day in many ways is ideal
for any kind of linear action oriented items.
If you had, and people will differ.
Some people say I do creative work best early in day,
but most people are gonna do best
at kind of correct answer type work,
meaning where there is a correct linear output
it's going to be accounting type work,
or it's going to be exercise,
where you might not know exactly what you're going to do
but there is a process that you can follow.
It's going to be punching out a certain amount of words
on a page,
'cause you're just trying to get
the words down on the page for the book,
or doing math, or doing any kind of linear operation
during that first phase one.
Phase two has a signature pattern
of neurotransmitter release in the brain and body
that are more closely associated, not exclusively,
but more closely associated
with the release of things like serotonin.
These are neuromodulators that tend to make us feel
a little bit calmer and they disrupt,
or I should say they alter
because it's not a pathological shift,
but they alter a perception of space and time
in a way that allows us to make mental associations
that are a little bit looser.
They can be non-linear.
So that's a time that's excellent for creative work
or for brainstorming.
And you might notice that when you're a little bit fatigued,
your mind is a little freer and if you're very fatigued,
your mind is all over the place.
So one thing that I think has been missing
from the brain state work
has been a kind of cohesive framework.
And yet everyone, I think every neuroscientist would agree
that the 24 hour cycle really governs,
not just digestion and bodily temperature,
'cause it does temperature is higher in the morning,
rising, rising, rising to the afternoon,
then starts coming down,
and then you go into sleep in phase three
'cause your body temperature is lowered.
So those three phases really drive our brain states
and one precedes the other.
This is the key thing.
We can never look at a state in isolation,
but if you wanted to understand, for instance,
how to access a state of heightened creativity,
you might try placing it in phase two of the day.
So 10 to 16 hours after you've been awake
and see how that works for you
and pay attention to your state of mind
before you at attempt to go into that state,
and as you exit that state.
And so I think that if we've learned anything
from the sleep science
it's that we can't look at one state of mind in isolation,
we need to ask what preceded it and what follows it
in order to understand its structure
and how to access it better.
At the same time,
human beings do their best to,
fuck with this by sugar, caffeine, alcohol,
like we're trying to perpetuate a certain state,
where we feel the best or we're the most productive
and that disrupts this natural like sort of preset
regarding the circadian rhythm
and the kind of hormonal regulatory balance
that we would experience without all of these inputs
that are screwing us up,
and impairing our sleep,
and ultimately have short-term gains obviously,
or we wouldn't do it but long term problems.
Yeah.
I think that there are basic things that if I may,
everyone should do in order to anchor their body
and their mind in the most productive rhythm
that they possibly can.
And the reason I feel comfortable saying this is that
we were not designed to be nocturnal,
we are capable of nocturnal activity.
And I wanna just give a nod to shift workers
and of all kinds that have to work
in the middle of the night.
I mean, that's the way the world works nowadays.
And there are a whole set of things
that shift workers suffer from;
digestive issues, mental health issues,
I mean, they're prone to more cardiac events and suicides.
I mean, it's obvious that shift work,
especially swing shift work
where people are alternating
their schedule pretty frequently
is extremely detrimental to brain and body.
And there are a number of things that people can do
to offset that.
I've done an episode of the podcast on that.
And I do some work with communities
that are restricted to shift work
to try and help offset that.
But for most people it's going to be heading to sleep
somewhere between 9:00 PM and midnight
and waking up somewhere between 5:00 AM and 9:00 AM.
I would think.
I mean, I'm thinking the college students
and my college years or sleeping in.
But there's tremendous value in anchoring one's biology
to this 24 hour cycle.
And it's very simple as to how to do that.
I mean, the most dominant zeitgeber as we say,
timekeeper that governs all these states,
including sleep is light.
There's no question about it.
And you ask any circadian biologists
to say there's a kind of a principle of circadian biology
which is that light is the dominant zeitgeber,
called zeitgeber 'cause the people who define this
were German.
And I'm pronouncing it incorrectly
because I don't speak German.
It's clear that if possible one should view sunlight
or at least get outside,
even if it's cloudy outside within the first hour of waking.
And if you wake up before the sun comes out
to flip on as many artificial lights as possible,
if your goal is to be awake,
if your goal is to go back asleep,
definitely keep the light dim.
But getting light in your eyes even through cloud cover
is going to set in motion
a number of different biological events,
read out first through certain cells in the eyes;
these so-called melanopsin and intrinsically
photosensitive ganglion cells as the fancy name,
they were discovered by David Berson at Brown University.
And they send a signal to your hypothalamus
which then sets in motion a huge number
of hormonal and neural events in the body.
They create a cortisol pulse that wakes you up further,
sets the baseline for your attention throughout the day,
also sets a timer of about 16 hours,
not coincidentally on your first melatonin pulse,
which will happen in the evening.
So it's timing when your sleep is going to come.
People who stay indoors in dark environments
for the early part of the day,
just looking at their phone,
you're not getting enough light stimulation.
The tricky thing is that later in the evening,
about 17 hours after you've been awake or when you woke up,
what you'll find is that even a minimum of light
from screens can shift your circadian clock.
And the reason is that there's a gradual shift
in the sensitivity of the retina to external light.
So you need a lot of light,
ideally sunlight early in the day,
and of course, you don't wanna stare directly at any light
that's so bright that it's painful,
you don't have to look directly into the sun,
absolutely blank.
You can be kind of off center from the sun,
but try and get out there without sunglasses if you can.
People always ask,
can I wear eyeglasses or contacts?
And I say,
absolutely because that actually will focus the light
to your retina.
And that's what they're designed to do.
Through a window or a windshield
simply will not work as well
because of the filtration of the wavelengths of light
that you want.
And then there's a lot of data to support the fact
that getting as much bright light in your eyes
throughout the day provided it's not painfully bright
is excellent for your wakefulness mechanisms,
and even for the mechanisms of the brain and body
that control metabolism and feeding, mood and wellbeing.
This is the work mainly of Samer Hattar
at the National Institutes of Mental Health.
He's the Head of the Chronobiology unit
So Samer would say,
get as much bright light in your eyes as you can
early in the day and throughout the day,
and then somewhere close to bedtime,
trough that and live in the darkest environment
you possibly can manage safely.
He's not a big fan of being
in completely light absent environments,
but that simple behavior of early light viewing most days,
if not all days sets in motion
these three phases that lend themselves best
to focused work, creative work, the ability to stay awake
most of the day.
Naps are fine we know,
provided they don't interfere with nighttime sleep.
So naps should be shorter than 90 minutes.
But if a nap of any duration prevents you from falling
and staying asleep at night, then you don't want to nap.
So light is the dominant way
that you set this whole process in motion.
And we know based on work that I wasn't involved in,
but that David Spiegel did with the great Robert Sapolsky,
that if these cortisol pulse doesn't arrive early enough
in the day and starts arriving in the afternoon,
that's a physiological signature of depression and anxiety.
So that cortisol pulse is happening one way or a another
and you wanna anchor to the early part of the day.
And so if you're feeling wide awake,
anxious in the sort of wired and tired late in the day,
chances are, you're not getting enough sunlight
early in the day and throughout the day.
Right.
So the delayed exposure to sunlight
in the early part of the day
can lead to that kind of depressed state.
Absolutely.
And it seems like it's an easy fix to ensure
that you're exposed to sunlight in an adequate way
in the early part of the day.
The end of the day part is harder in our modern lives.
We could do things with our screens
and make sure they're off.
Is there a qualitative difference between the light
that's being emitted from the screens that we're looking at
versus the overhead lights in our indoor environments?
We're just in light until it's time to flick the light off
and close our eyes.
Yeah, it's a great question.
One of the things that I think can be very useful,
again, is anchored in the biology of the system,
is that so the melanopsin cells reside mostly,
not exclusively in the lower half of the retina
and they view the upper visual field.
That makes sense because these were cells
that were essentially evolved
to extract sunlight information.
They're not involved in pattern vision,
they're involved in gauging how much light there is
in our overall environment.
In the evening,
a lot of people now know to dim their screens,
dim the lights, but if possible,
also try and shift to an environment
where if you do have lights,
make them desk lamps, or if you're really extreme,
you can make them floor lamps,
but try not to have too much bright overhead lighting.
And I suppose if you work in an environment
where you can't avoid that,
if they allow you to wear a hat or a broomed hat
or something of that sort, that could work fine too.
A lot of people like blue blockers,
they are not necessary in most cases,
but I shouldn't say that, excuse me,
they can be very useful if you're stuck
in a bright environment
to screen out some of the wavelengths of light
that can wake up your circadian clock, so to speak.
Because light inhibits melatonin, very potently.
And yet if you're in a very bright environment,
it doesn't matter what wavelengths you screen out
these cells will be activated.
So blue blockers alone won't do the job,
you also need to try and dim screens
and ideally physically lower the lights in your environment,
or at least turn off the lights overhead
and rely on lights that are further down
physically in the room.
And the converse of that is during the day
having as many bright lights above you is terrific.
And so I found a simple, low cost solution to this.
I don't wanna name any brands
'cause I don't have an affiliation with any of them.
But a lot of people ask about daylight simulators.
I've found that the least expensive
and most effective thing, frankly,
is to just get a ring light of the sort design
for selfie type stuff
and just put it on your desk where work throughout the day.
And that's giving you a lot of additional photons,
bright light.
But you would also do well
to do some of your workout on a deck,
if you can, get outside and take walks, if you can.
We know that the stimuli for setting these brain states
are light, temperature, movement, food
and social interactions,
but it all really starts with light.
And if we were to talk about temperature,
it's clear that everyone
has what's called their temperature minimum.
So I should just ask you this,
we can do the experiment in real time.
What time do you normally wake up more or less?
Generally about six.
Okay.
So we can estimate that your lowest body temperature
across the entire 24 hour cycle
probably occurs somewhere around 3:30 or 4:00 AM.
So your goal is to get sunlight in your eyes
in the two to four hours
following that temperature minimum.
If you were to get bright light in your eyes
in the two to four hours before that temperature minimum,
it would push your clock out of phase,
it would be like traveling.
And then the key point here is that most people nowadays
are jetlagged even though they're not traveling.
And so when we feel anxious or disrupted,
or we have our sleep is fractured into two major phases,
which isn't entirely normal, but abnormal, excuse me.
But when we are having all sorts of issues,
a lot of times it just brings us back to the question of,
are you getting the major stimulus
for your autonomic nervous system
to wake up at one time of day and be quiet,
or quiescent and sleepy at another time of day,
are you getting that stimulus on a consistent basis?
And for people that are in the Northeast or in the UK,
and they say, "Well, you should see how much light
is coming through right now, it's like zilch."
It's really dark.
More photons are coming through that dense cloud cover
than you're ever gonna get from your tablet or your phone.
At the same time,
seasonal affect disorder is like a real thing, right?
I have a really hard time every winter,
I get into funk,
I slide into this semi depressed state
where I just have a really hard time
getting enthusiastic about anything.
I assume that that's related to the wavelengths of light
and what I'm being exposed to
as well as temperature, et cetera,
and I've exposed myself to ring light
and all that kind of off,
helps a little bit, but it doesn't really ameliorate it.
And what's interesting is even if I travel
to a warm climate and it's tropical or whatever,
it's still that time of year
where the days are short,
unless I go below to go to Australia or South America
or something like that.
And so it only ameliorates it in part,
even though I'm in a warm environment,
I still kind of can feel that
washed over me until the days start getting longer.
Yeah.
Well, there are of couple mechanisms for this.
First of all, the dopamine system,
it does many things in the;
body responsible for movement,
motivation, craving, et cetera.
But dopamine is very strongly regulated
by seasonality in a lot of animals.
In fact, for the animal lovers out there
and the wildlife lovers of which I am,
the shift in pelage color,
that animals will have white or very pale fur
in one time of the year
and then it gets darker
is actually due to a light regulated shift in dopamine.
So when it turns out that when days are short
and nights are long, levels of dopamine are reduced,
this probably also explains the reduced mood
that you experience to some extent or another.
And dopamine is in this tyrosinase pathway,
people can look this up,
that is upstream of the melanin pathway
and as a consequence, pelage becomes white.
In the spring and summer months
when animals are getting more sun,
there's an activation through the eyes,
again, activates the dopamine system,
the dopamine system then triggers the melanin system
to produce darkening of the pelage, right?
And there's all sorts of amplification
in seasonally breeding animals
where animals testes involute, it's a horrible term,
but they involute in the winter
and ovaries will involute too.
In other words, they shrink a species of hamster actually
where the Siberian hamster,
where it's testes are about the size of a grain of rice
during the winter,
and then they increased by more than a thousand fold
in the spring or summer.
That's so crazy.
So there's these massive shifts.
Now, humans are not restricted to season only breeding.
I mean, after all I was born in September,
so that doesn't work
'cause I'm imagining if all things
still work the way they they do now
that I was conceived sometime in December.
There's a multitude of factors.
Yeah.
I don't know the story about conception
nor do I want to know,
but nonetheless humans are subject to more subtle mood
based variations and physiology shifts across the year.
And the reason is the following:
Light comes in,
triggers these intrinsically photosensitive cells,
then trigger a pathway that eventually converges
not just on the circadian clock and the hypothalamus,
but on the pineal gland.
And the pineal is responsible for secretion of melatonin.
So when days are long because light inhibits melatonin,
the pulse of melatonin,
the duration of your melatonin pulse as we call it
is very short,
when days are short and nights are very long
there's less light to inhibit melatonin,
and so there's a long melatonin signal.
The melatonin know it does a number of things,
it makes you sleepy, et cetera,
it's gonna make you feel a little bit more subdued,
but it has a number of downstream effects as well.
So what I would suggest for people
that experience moderate seasonal depression
would be to really emphasize
trying to get as much bright light in your eyes
as you can outside, and if appropriate,
there's a study out of Israel that shows
that exposing as much of your bodily surface to light
actually can be useful too.
And for the following reason,
we think of skin as just this barrier to outside stuff,
which it is, but it's actually an endocrine organ.
It can secrete hormones
through where it can direct the secretion of hormones.
There's a pathway involving something called P57,
and it's a beautiful paper
that described how people who get two of upper body,
most of upper body sunlight exposure
have greatly increased levels of both testosterone
and estrogen in the appropriate ratios
in men and women, et cetera,
and improved mood, and improved libido, improved metabolism.
The metabolism study is kind of a separate study,
but nonetheless,
it's not just about getting sunlight of on your eyes,
it's also about getting it onto your skin,
which typically we only do in the spring and summer months.
So again, if appropriate,
try and expose as much of yourself to sunlight as possible.
And I should say, no, this is not a reinforcement
for this trend that was taking over Instagram
a few years ago of sunning every orifice on your body.
That was more, I think about...
I think we all know what you're talking about.
That was more of a subculture phenomenon,
and as far as I know,
there are no laboratory data to support that.
That would be a study that would be hard to get approved.
I wanna switch gears here a little bit
and talk about performance states.
I feel like as an athlete,
I was taught certain things
and I just naturally developed my own habits
around getting into an optimal performance state.
Visualization has always been a tool,
but also intentional breathing practices,
without any instruction, it's just you watch people,
for example, in swimming behind the blocks at the Olympics,
they're all taking deep breaths,
it's almost as if their body is telling 'em
what they need to do to induce a state
in which they can perform at their absolute peak.
But I've also been in situations where now I go on stage
to give a talk and sometimes I'm very relaxed
and it goes great,
and other times I'm hyperventilating,
and I'm sweating, and I'm nervous,
and I can't catch my breath, and I can't get a word out.
Like I've exceeded the performance state
and I'm in a state of induced panic, right?
So what are some practices, 'cause everybody,
whether you have to give a presentation at work,
or make a difficult phone call,
or have an uncomfortable conversation,
we all have moments in our life
where we wanna kind of execute to the best of our abilities.
And I know that there's many things
that we can do to kind of ensure
that we're in the best position
for the outcome that we seek.
Yeah.
Before I answer, I just have to ask,
is there any correlation with what you described
with how well you've slept the night before?
Oh, a 100%.
Like when I sleep really well, I'm alert, but I'm calm.
I have a sense of confidence that comes easy,
words come easy, thoughts come easy,
my memory is better, my recall, all of that.
If I don't sleep well,
and often I don't particularly when I have to give a speech
in front of a lot of people
because that induces a lot of anxiety in me
and that I don't rest well.
And then I wake up and I'm already off my game,
and then I'm in some sort of damage control.
And often I find myself in a vicious circle
that just makes it worse
and then there I am on stage
and just delivering a C-minus performance.
Although I doubt it.
(both chattering)
You're your own toughest critic.
Definitely.
I have a lot to learn when it comes to that art form.
You're an excellent speaker.
I hear the Stanford student in you
and very self critical.
But look, self criticism is also the gateway
to high performance over time, right?
Okay, so in terms of thinking about accessing states
and self-directing states for performance,
we should probably return to this notion
of the autonomic seesaw,
because we are all slaves to this process of alert but calm,
or stressed, or sleepy, et cetera.
The reason I asked about sleep is that
the way to think about the autonomic nervous system
is that it's not truly autonomic.
And autonomic means automatic.
We actually can exert some control over it.
We can have certain kinds of conversations and not others.
We can breathe faster or more slowly.
As we talked about before you can use your visual system
in a number of ways.
So we can exert control over this thing
that we're calling the autonomic nervous system
or the seesaw.
Perhaps a better way to visualize it is that
you're sort of like a, imagine yourself as a stick figure,
that's you on the autonomic seesaw
and under well rested, well prepared conditions,
you can move by back and forth across that seesaw,
you can kind of surf that seesaw all day long.
And the hinge on that seesaw so to speak
is of the appropriate tightness and looseness
so that makes it very easy.
When we're sleep deprived,
there's a tendency for us to find
that getting from one end of the seesaw to the other
is a little bit more strenuous.
And I've talked to Matt Walker
about some of the underlying circuits
that might reflect the hinge might actually be,
and that's something that we might collaborate on
in the future.
But it's very clear that when we're well rested,
we can surf this seesaw pretty well.
We feel stressed and we can kind of take a deep breath,
calm ourselves, tell ourselves,
okay, that person's nuts or that person is,
I'll deal with that later.
But when we're sleep deprived we compromise our ability
to do this.
Okay.
Regardless of whether or not you're well rested or not,
it's clear that there's a small handful of tools
that can allow one to direct their movement
along the seesaw more efficiently.
The first one is one that we talked about before
which is the physiological sigh.
And I'm not here to promote....
First of all, I didn't discover it.
I don't own it.
It was Jack Feldman that really understood
the neural machinery,
but physiological sighs have been known about
since the 1930s,
as a way to reset the oxygen, CO2 balance in the system.
If ones feeling stressed or I should just say more alert
than one would like to be,
under any conditions physiological sighs
are at least to my knowledge
the fastest way to bring down that level of alertness.
And again, it's a full inhale through the nose
as deeply as you possibly can,
and then sneak in a little bit more air at the top,
that's gonna inflate the maximum number of alveoli
and then a long exhale
until basically you have no more air to exhale.
And how many times do you do that?
We find that just once is often enough,
but maybe three times maximum.
Now that's very different
than the five minute physiological sighing practice
that we were talking about before.
This is what I would call a real time tool.
And this is something that my lab has been really interested
in developing because so many of the things
that make us able to form well involved,
taking us out of the arena that we're in, it's meditation,
it's a massage, it's a great night's sleep,
it's quality social interaction and nutrition,
and of course, we should still all do all of those things
as often as we can,
but there's this double edged sword about,
or I should say,
there's this very diabolical aspect to stress
which is that when we are stressed,
oftentimes we can't remove ourself from the stress
or the thing that's stressing us.
And oftentimes we are compromised in our ability
to access the states of mind and good sleep
and all those sorts of things.
You even alluded to that in your description.
So physiological sighs are an excellent real time tool
for dealing with things in real time.
The other thing that's clearly useful
is for people to get comfortable
at high levels of autonomic arousal.
And in many ways
this could be thought of as raising one's stress threshold.
And here I have to give a nod wim hof type breathing,
also which is very similar to tumor type breathing,
which is very similar
to what we call cyclic hyperventilation in the lab.
But basically having a practice
that you do away from the event,
it doesn't necessarily have to be done every day,
but maybe three times a week or so
of deliberately putting your autonomic nervous system,
excuse me, into a state of very high autonomic arousal.
So this would involve doing 20 or 30 really deep breaths
in through the nose and then exhaling very intensely.
Normally our inhales are active and our exhales are passive.
In reptilian species it's the opposite,
it's kind of interesting.
Their exhales tend to be active
and their inhales tend to be passive,
but for humans, we tend to inhale
and then just let the air kind of drift out of us.
When you both inhale intensely and exhale intensely
20 or 30 times, you're going to quote unquote "heat up."
That's the release of adrenaline from your adrenals.
There's no question about that.
You could also get into a cold shower,
you could also do an ice bath, you could do submersion,
you could do any number of things
provided that it makes you uncomfortable.
What you're doing is you're tipping that seesaw
and you're doing it deliberately.
And then immediately after that 20 or 30 breaths,
you exhale all your air.
What I'm describing is classic tumor wim hof type breathing
to many people,
and you hold your breath and try
and maintain a state of mental calm
despite being flooded with adrenaline.
And then you repeat, and then you repeat again,
and maybe you do that three or four rounds.
Some people include big inhales with breath holds.
I should point out that none of this should be done
anywhere near water,
not even standing next to a puddle
because people have blacked out and drown in ice baths
and in oceans, and people have died
doing this type of thing,
because of the ability that you can't breathe underwater
and the shallow water blackout phenomenon.
So I wanna emphasize that people who have a high degree
of anxiety or who suffer from panic attacks
are not going to want to do this,
unless they're doing this with clinical support right there.
But for most people and for sake of high performance,
getting very comfortable in high levels of adrenaline
pumping through your system can be immensely useful,
such that when you get hit by something from the outside,
like the sudden appearance of an elevated heart rate
for reasons you don't understand,
you can sort of third person from that in recognizing,
"I've been in this state before."
It's sort of like when you learn how to drive,
you do it around the parking lot
and you do it in the local roads,
and then the first time you drive in really dense fog
on a mountain road, and you're scared for your life,
it's one reflector at a time.
You make it through that, the next time it's two reflectors
you're like, "Okay, don't like this could get rear ended
anytime could go off a cliff, but I've been here before."
Well, lot's useful practice.
I didn't mean to interrupt.
A lot of that has to do with the root of the anxiety
and often that's traced
to a relationship with control, right?
You wanna control the outcome.
If you're an athlete and you have a game, or a performance,
or whatever it is, it's that idea of,
I want this to go a certain way,
I only have control over some of these variables.
How am I gonna be perceived?
What happens if X, Y, or Z happens in an unexpected way?
Which is why I found visualization to be a powerful tool
and I've generally used that or deployed it
to visualize success,
like walking myself mentally through every step
of what's gonna happen
and kind of plotting how it's gonna turn out
in a favorable way.
But I know that you have some thoughts around doing that
in a failure context as well.
So you're getting a comprehensive view of all the things
that could happen,
which could then kind of calm yourself down
because you've considered it all.
Yeah.
So there's some interesting data, actually modeling data,
mean computational models of learning that's say,
what should the percentage of successful trials
versus failed trials be
when you're trying to learn something?
So this is a little bit different than high performance
in the context of competition or the onstage performance
where we're really talking about training at this point.
And there are a couple of interesting things about this.
First of all, the number
that falls out of this really nice paper is that
the best level of difficulty for something
should be approximately successful trials 85% of the time,
15% of trials should be failed trials.
And obviously this will vary by context,
if you're learning piano
versus if you're shooting on a range,
or different for cognitive tasks from math, et cetera.
But this 85/15 rule seems to work well
for the understanding of how the underlying neural networks
for learning work.
So that's hopefully we'll give people
a little bit of guidance in terms of structuring
their training or of their learning
in a way that it's appropriate levels of difficulty,
neither too difficult, nor too easy.
The other thing that's very clear is that
the process of neuroplasticity
as I mentioned, has two steps, major steps.
One is focus, and then one is deep rest.
Most of the rewiring and learning in your nervous system
is going to occur during deep sleep.
And so obviously try and get sufficient
amount of quality sleep, slow wave and REM sleep
as much as possible.
But there are two really nice papers
published in the journal Cell Reports,
the Cell Press journal, excellent journal,
which show that even brief 20 minute periods of resting
or napping after a learning bout
can greatly accelerate the neuroplasticity process.
So whether or not you're trying to learn a new motor skill,
whether or not you have just done an intense visualization,
which can be relaxing
but it's really a form of training and repetition,
whether or not you're learning math, or piano,
or whatever it is that in some period of time
within the immediate four hours after the learning bout
or the visualization,
to get 20 minutes of maybe a shallow nap,
you could do what we call non-sleep deep breath,
some people call it yoga nidra.
There are other forms of non-sleep deep breath,
essentially letting the brain go idle, closing your eyes.
I should say this is work done in humans,
it was done sensory, motor learning and complex sequences
of a kind of assign assess game,
which is hitting some people won't remember what that is,
but remembering the sequences of light
and it can be very easy
when there's only three or four things in that sequence
because you get up to 20 or 30,
that's subserous work.
The other thing that really favors neuroplasticity
or what are called gap effects.
And these date back more than a couple decades
and have been demonstrated in a huge variety of context
of learning.
But anytime you're learning something,
it pays to have random intervals in which you stop
and do nothing.
So let's use learning a sequence of the keys on the piano
just for sake of example.
You're practicing a scale.
You're practicing a piece music.
Every once in a while,
if you have a timer that goes off randomly,
or the instructor or teacher tells you stop,
and you attempt to do nothing,
you could close your eyes or keep them open
but you stop the motor pattern
or you stop trying to do the math problem,
or you stop trying to do the physical sequence
that you were doing.
Turns out that when we sleep,
there's a rapid replay of these sequences
of events during the day, but at much higher speed.
So for per unit time,
you're getting about 10 to 60 times the replay or repetition
of what you're doing during the day.
During these brief gaps,
these 10 second gaps that are introduced while awake,
during your learning,
you get a 10 to 20 times repeat
of whatever sequence you were trying to learn.
So this is a way of getting more repetitions in,
even though you're doing less.
And so these gap effects are fascinating.
They're being demonstrated now for more and more
types of learning.
And fortunately the more recent papers
really point to the neural mechanisms,
it's the hippocampus and the neocortex
areas involved in storage and retrieval of memories
that are rapidly replaying these sequences.
We talked about how one state defines the next.
So when you're repeating something over and over and over,
you stop the nervous system
doesn't just switch to what you're doing,
it keeps generating that sequence.
And when you suddenly limit your motor behavior,
your cognitive behavior,
so you're maybe reciting lines to remember
and all of a sudden you just stop
and you attempt to stop doing that,
your mind keeps going
and that accelerates the number of repetitions
and then you return to the practice.
Why has that not been incorporated
into our educational system?
I mean, that's crazy.
That seems like such a turbo blast
in our ability to synthesize information
that it should be part and parcel
of how we are approaching our curriculums.
Well, first of all,
I have two responses to that.
First of all,
I've made some attempt to put that out there.
There's a free lecture that I did
thanks to the support of Logitech.
There's a free online lecture
that was specifically for teachers
and some steps to gaining more rapid neuroplasticity.
Because I think teachers are hungry
for better ways to teach their students.
I think I can speculate
having been in the field of neuroscience
for a long while now
that there was so much excitement about neuroplasticity
and BDNF, or neuroplasticity and nerve growth factor.
All these frankly, hard to access mechanisms
that people were thinking,
what can I eat?
What can I do in order to enhance my learning?
What's gonna trigger BDNF release?
When in fact the process of neuroplasticity
is built into our childhood and how we developed
for better or for worse, right?
Hence the discussion about trauma.
But there are a couple elements to neuroplasticity
that we now know require focus and then rest.
So the number one support for learning
is gonna be deep sleep, regular deep sleep.
So if kids wanna learn better, adults wanna learn better
that's the thing to focus on first.
That's really the anchor to everything.
And we know this.
And for people that feel anxiety,
hearing this realize that you are resilient,
you can have a poor night's, but I would say,
try and get great sleep about 80% of the time.
But that sleep is really the thing to focus on
until it's in place to get everything else to work well.
But these other things like gap learning effects,
they've been in the literature,
but they've never actually been translated into protocols
for the real world.
And so the neuroscience field
is sort of guilty of placing things in language and context
that's been really hard to access,
and kind of there have been people who have attempted
to unvault this stuff.
People like Mike Mesnick from UCSF,
John Brady from Harvard Medical School.
But I think in the '80s and '90s
and early 2000s, the world wasn't really ready for it.
And here's the case where social media wasn't there,
there weren't a lot of online learning platform
for people to hear about this stuff.
And I wanna be very clear.
I have nothing to do with this specific research.
I am the academic descendant of some people
who did very well in their discovery
of critical periods of neuroplasticity,
but this isn't my work,
but I am absolutely overwhelmingly enthusiastic
about this work, 'cause I like we can all benefit from it.
And this is absolutely free.
There's no product to purchase.
There's no thing to do except to introduce these short gaps.
And then after learning to take a 20 minute nap if you can,
or just try and shut off the amount of sensory input
coming in.
And again, that doesn't have to happen immediately
after the learning,
but at some period in the next four hours
because we know that recall, persistence of the memory
of what you learned and the ability to execute
these motor sequences just goes way up.
Yeah.
It's so crazy how we've historically gotten it backwards.
Like whether you're a med student, or a college student,
or law school, or whatever it is.
It's all about cramming, staying up all night,
exhausting yourself, showing up for the test,
doing the dump and then crashing for a couple days,
which is completely antithetical
to maximizing your performance.
Yeah.
Unfortunately Stanford understands the biology
and so they don't do this at Stanford Medicine
or that in medical school,
many places students are sleep deprived
and the residents on call.
I mean, we all know that I'm gonna get in trouble
for saying this with the medical community,
but I'll say it.
If you end up in the hospital in the middle of the night,
you should ask how long the physician has been there.
I mean, fatal mistakes have been made.
Right. So yeah.
(both chattering)
The people that we turn over complete control
of our lives over to,
yeah, air traffic controllers, pilots, surgeons,
people that are on these crazy shifts.
Yeah, exactly.
It makes no sense.
And the consequences are many and they're severe.
I mean, they really can be severe.
I don't know what it's like in law school,
but I wanna make sure that any lawyer I hire
has actually been rested for the learning of the material.
Who knows what the lawyers are doing?
I certainly, don't.
Not a lot of sleep in law school.
All right, well, we gotta round this out,
but maybe let's close it down
with a recap or a supplementation of some of the practices
that people who are listening or watching
can begin to incorporate into their lives.
We talked about some of the breathwork practices,
exposure to light, sleep, we've talked about.
We don't need to go super into nutrition,
although that's super important,
but maybe just a few things
that people can start thinking about and practicing.
Yeah, I think the most important things
are the foundational practices,
which are get your sleep right.
Best way to get your sleep right
is get your morning sunlight exposure,
ideally within an hour of waking up.
Again, if you wake up before the sun comes out,
flip on as many lights as you possibly can,
if you want to be awake, right?
That's one basic way
to just set the whole thing in motion properly.
I think everyone should have a real time tool
for dealing with stress, the physiological sighs,
the best one that I'm aware of.
And it's grounded in close to a hundred years
in physiology and excellent work
in a variety of laboratories.
I think that people should also
have a way of increasing their stress threshold.
And there's a lot made nowadays of ice baths
and cold showers for dopamine release,
and there is evidence for that, believe it or not.
Extended dopamine release from cold showers,
or ice baths, or just cold immersion.
That can be very useful.
I also think it's just very useful
to have some sort of breathing practice
or cold water exposure practice
that you do maybe three to seven times a week,
depending on how aggressive you are
to raise your stress threshold
so that you can manage under conditions of high adrenaline.
And your minimum effective dose
for that is pretty nominal.
Yeah.
So there was a beautiful study published,
the first author is Dr. Susanna Sobad,
this was a study done
at Scandinavia published in Cell Reports Medicine.
I've spent a lot of time with this study.
It was mainly focused on the metabolic effects
of cold exposure.
Showing that if you want to be comfortable
in cold environments,
the best thing you can do
is get into a very cold environment
for about 11 minutes total per week.
They also saw metabolic increases.
You also see increases in resilience,
which is basically translate to an ability
to stay mentally calm when you have a lot of adrenaline.
You can do this with cold showers.
You can do this with immersion up to the neck.
A lot of people say, which is better?
Immersion is better, mostly because it's been studied more.
It's hard to do studies on showers
because people don't always stand in the same depth.
The shower has immersion is one way, et cetera.
If you don't have access to either of those,
yes, you could go outside in cold conditions,
but the heat transfer in water is much greater.
So 11 minutes total translates to two or three minutes
as many times a week as needed
to hit about that 11 minute threshold,
is really going to improve your brown a post tissue stores.
These are tissue stores that generate heats
kinda like a furnace in your body,
increase metabolism,
increase this thing we're calling resilience
or stress tolerance.
So 11 minutes per week.
A lot of data also about sauna, et cetera.
But I'll just say,
if you are somebody doing cold exposure, people say,
"Can I end with a warm shower or hot shower?"
That's what I do, 'cause I like it.
You're not supposed to do that.
If you want to increase your metabolism,
you will end with cold so that you have to continue
to use your bodily functions,
your metabolism more in order to reheat.
Shivering is actually a good thing.
There's evidence that shivering from the muscle
can release something called suckeny,
which triggers the more brown fat accumulation
which is not the blubbery fat
that most people wanna get rid of,
but is the fat that generates this heat in the body.
So those are good practices to have.
So 11 minutes of cold exposure total per week
divided into several sessions.
But if it ends up being six minutes and five minutes,
that's fine too.
I imagine it's never really been looked at
and I can only imagine having talked to Susan Sobad
that that would be good as well.
So have a real time tool,
have a tool to increase resilience or stress tolerance.
Then also try and limit your light exposure in the evening.
Try and dim those lights, bring them low in the environment,
try and make the room cool, so you can sleep well.
Pile on the blankets if you want.
That doesn't mean being cold,
it means having your environment be cold
so you can toss off the blankets as needed
and get deep sleep.
The other things I think could be very useful
is to think about this three view of states,
both in sleep and awake,
that from zero to eight or nine hours after waking,
that's going to be high energy, high output,
high adrenaline on just naturally high cortisol.
So linear type of operations that people always say,
"What's your morning routine?
Do you do the most difficult thing early in the day?"
Not necessarily, sometimes if you do the most boring,
terrible thing in day,
which for me would be like an Excel spreadsheet.
For me is just,
I'd rather get hives than do an Excel spreadsheet,
but the most difficult thing might be the creative work
which would fall, or brainstorming work,
or what we would call non-linear type thing,
taking existing elements but arranging them in new ways,
are probably best done for most people
in the second phase of the day.
And then of course from 17 to 24 hours after waking,
you wanna be asleep.
Naps and deep rest are terrific.
Limit them to 90 minutes or less,
and don't do them at all if they inhibit your ability
to sleep at night.
And then in terms of additional resources,
or tools I should say that the gap effects introduced
during learning at random.
So 10 second gaps introduced at random,
what the proper ratio is.
So let's say you're doing an hour long training bout,
you might introduce a kind of a 10 to one.
So for every 10 minutes, excuse me,
for every 10 minutes of training,
you might introduce one of these gaps.
You could do them more frequently.
It really hasn't been explored
how often to introduce these gaps,
but they should arrive more or less at random.
Is that a situation like, for example,
you're reading a textbook, you're a student.
So you read a certain section for 10 minutes
and then you get up and walk around for a minute,
or is there something out moving the body
that enhances that?
In general, these have been studied
simply because it's a laboratory setting
by simply having people stop,
and either eyes open or eyes closed
just to try and limit the amount of sensory input
and motor movement.
Doesn't mean that walking around wouldn't help,
but you certainly don't wanna look at your phone
that's bringing in additional information.
That might even,
we could speculate would inhibit this ability
for the hippocampus to engage this more...
You're essentially getting more reps during the rest, right?
And then of course, the learning,
the ratio that seems about right is make things challenging,
such that about 15% of the time you're getting things wrong,
85% of the time you're getting things correct.
And then we touched on a few other things,
some naps and deep sleep,
or shallow naps immediately after a learning bout,
I should say, within the four hour period
after a learning bout.
And then if you're interested in hypnosis,
which is indeed a very powerful tool for a lot of people,
depending on how hypnotizable they're going to be.
That Reveri app I think is extremely useful.
I've been using it to improve my sleep.
Somehow in the last year, my sleep got fractured,
I always seemed to wake up at 3:00 AM.
I was struggling to get back to sleep
and so I will use the sleep script
in the Reveri app during the day.
It teaches you to get better at sleeping
and if I wake up in the middle of the night
I use that to get right back to sleep.
And after now I'm very hypnotizable.
So for me, it's worked very well,
but there are clinical data and research data
to support the hypnosis scripts in Reveri.
I'm bummed that I'm not so hypnotizable.
Well, an we should just get Spiegel here
for a richer conversation.
I would love to talk to him.
And I know he'd love to talk to you.
He has incredible stories about how hypnosis emerged
as a clinical practice and it's various uses.
He talks about people who've had
what they thought was asthma,
but it was a kind of anxiety induced asthma,
and the use of hypnosis and clearing that up
in single sessions.
So hypnosis is powerful,
and I wish there was a different name for it,
so that neural rescripting or something.
But then it sounds like some sort of online program.
And all of this was, I should say,
all the work on hypnosis will say,
was paid for by federal tax dollars, and the NIH,
and donors and things of that sort as well.
But this is serious science.
The work that Spiegel and his colleagues do
is serious science around generating neuroplasticity
through this,
trying to access the both end of the seesaw simultaneously.
Well, I think we did it, man.
I suppose we have.
How do you feel?
I feel grateful that you had me back on,
and I'm always grateful
when I get to sit down with Richroll.
I'm gonna embarrass you even further by saying,
even though we've known each other for some time,
and I'm very comfortable around you
because I read your book first
and because I so admire what you've done and what you do,
whenever I'm in your presence
I'm also just fanning out a little bit.
Oh, come on, man.
That's crazy.
You're superstar.
I don't say it's a flatter you,
I say 'cause it's true.
So maybe someday my autonomic nervous system will adjust.
I'm trying to get better at receiving that kind of stuff.
So I appreciate that.
And I appreciate what you do.
It really is a gift to humanity,
and you're so talented at it
and can't wait to see what you do next.
I know you're working on a book,
so hopefully we'll have something to read pretty soon.
Hopefully someday.
Get around.
Did my editor ask you to say that?
And you're always welcome here.
And I think, do you have some like live events coming up
or what's coming down the pike for you?
Yeah, so we're gonna definitely continue with the podcast,
the solo episodes.
And then I love having the guests on that's so much fun
to showcase their incredible work.
And then I am gonna do some live events.
So May 17th, I'll be doing a live event in Seattle,
May 18th in Portland.
And then toward the end of the year in the fall and winter,
I'll be doing some live events in some other cities.
Yeah. Fantastic.
Well, we'll put all the appropriate links in the show notes
and let's go for round three when you're ready,
when the book's out.
Terrific. Thanks so much, Rich.
All right, man.
Thanks. Peace.
(upbeat music)